on eu une table
ronde dans les jours qui ont suivi le 7
octobre avec Dominique moisi Frédéric
Ansel et Ellie Barnavi qui était à à à à
TelAviv et qui a participé à cette
réunion en en visio une réunion tout à
fait passionnante d'ailleurs qui a
marqué très vite le la la prise de
distance par rapport à des positions
trop malquennes trop simplistes ici et
là bon la situation c'est évidemment
développé
détérioré dans des conditions qui
impressionnent
chacun
qui des situations de souffrance de de
mort de deuil euh d'incompréhension de
mouvements aineux de
développement par exemple de
l'antisémitisme tout un ensemble de
choses qui sont effrayants et sur un
fond de d'incertitude internationale et
d'incertitude sur la situation
internationale et également
d'incertitude sur le la politique même
qui est suivi par les protagonistes et
d'abord par Israël alors on a pensé
qu'effectivement Gill kepppel serait un
interlocuteur
particulièrement précieux
pour nous et Cher Gill je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être venu devant cette
commission je dis vous serez vous serez
je sais pas si vous êtes prophète en
votre pays mais vous serez prophète
devant votre commission et
donc je crois qu'il est un peu inutile
de vous présenter mais je vais le faire
un peu quand même vous êtes un
universitaire mondialement connu pour
vos ouvrages et réflexion votre premier
livre le Prophète et Pharaon publié en
80 4 analyser l'islamisme militant
contemporain et c'est évidemment une en
Égypte en Égypte oui en Égypte oui c'est
évidemment une oui l'allusion
pharaonique était CLA
euh une référence pour chacun en en 97
vous avez publié les bonslieux de
l'islam qui a été aussi un ouvrage
pionnier dans l'étude de l'islam en
Occident vous avez été directeur de
recherche au CNRS professeur associé à
Columbia l'Université de New York à la
LSI à Londres et not Colombia c'est
intéressant je savoir comment vous
percevez aujourd'hui en tant qu'ancien
Columbia ce qui se passe sur les campus
américains euh je peux pas citer tous
vos tous vos livre je mentionnerai
sortir du chaos les crises en
Méditerranée et au Moyen-Orient qui a
brillamment analysé les différents
événements majeurs au Moyen-Orient
depuis la guerre d'octobre
1973 et évidemment aujourd'hui votre
votre
livre prophète prophète en son pays
c'est comme ça qui s'intitule prophète
en son pays qui un titre assez
provocateur que ce qui me surprend pas
du tout de vous
bon nous sommes très heureux de vous
entendre la situation chacun la connaît
chacun la la Ve mais je crois que nous
vous ce que nous attendons de vous
c'est
essentiellement deux grands coups de
projecteur d'abord sur la sur la nature
du problème auquel nous sommes auquel le
monde est
confronté vous avez éclairé de façon
très très
intéressante le les évolution des
différentes mouvances musulmane
notamment vous avez inventé le concept
je crois que c'est vous qui l'avez
inventé mais il est extrêmement
éclairant dans la circonstance actuelle
de fréros chiisme c'est-à-dire
l'alliance de deux mouvements religieux
séparés par le dogme mais uni par la
radicalité si je pe peut-être est un peu
sommire uni par la radicalité et par le
combat donc radical sur la question
d'Israël d'une façon générale ça serait
très intéressant que vous essayez de
situer pour nous quelle est exactement
la selon vous la place du Hamas dans la
mouvance arabe à la fois par rapport au
mouvement palestinien qui est un
mouvement qui était initialement pas du
tout religieux qui était beaucoup plus
national qui comportait d'ailleurs une
forte minorité chrétienne qui n'était
pas d'ailleurs la plus modérée si on se
rappelle l'action de Monsieur abach mais
qui était quand même même tout à fait
différente de nature la position de
Hamas la position par rapport au régime
islamique modéré la position par rapport
au
chiit tout ça est très très peu perçu
notamment la la responsabilité directe
indirecte ou inexistante de l'Iran dans
le déclenchement des de l'opération du 7
octobre je ne trouve pas que quand je
lis la presse on soit très bien
documenté sur cette question est-ce que
ils l'ont fait tout seul est-ce qu'ils
l'ont fait avec la complicité de l'Iran
et ou est-ce que l'Iran a béni
rétrospectivement si je puis dire une
situation dont il essayait de tirer
profit et qui en même temps présentait
des menaces pour le pays donc je crois
que là il y a il y a quelque chose de
tout à fait tout à fait important pour
éclairer l'origine de ce qui s'est passé
et là je crois que personne n'est plus
compétent que vous pour le faire et puis
évidemment à l'autre bout du dispositif
après avoir analysé certains éléments de
l'origine du conflit nous sommes
évidemment totalement perplexe sur la
sortie nous ne sommes pas les seuls
depuis le début j'ai dit que je ne
comprenais pas quelles étaient les
options possibles de monsieur netanahou
qui avait exprimé des options très très
radicales en terme instrumental aplatir
le Liban détruire le le le la la la Gaza
et cetera et mais en revanche avait été
et toujours extrêmement soit discret
soit incertain et indéterminé sur la
solution la sortie politique qu'il qu'il
envisage or la sortie politique soit
c'est une sortie politique de
confrontation durable permanente fondée
sur le mur d'Israël par rapport à
l'ensemble de son voisinage soit c'est
l'espoir de dégager à à partir du monde
musulman euh des forces de stabilité des
forces de
déc et qui pourrai le moment venu
déboucher sur un processus de paix qui
est totalement à reconstruire et qui ne
peut pas être mis en œuvre immédiatement
sans qu'il y ait des des opération
préalable importante et ça là encore
c'est la diversité du monde arabe la
diversité du monde musulman au-delà du
monde arabe parce qu'il y a les Turcs il
y a les les Iraniens et c'est la qui qui
qui permet de de comprendre ce que
pourrait être les éventuels scénarios
possibles de sortie alors voyez cher
Gill on vous demande pas quelque chose
de simple mais ça quand on écrit un
livre sur le fait qu'on pourrait être un
prophète il est normal qu'on vous
demande une
prophétie en tout cas merci d'être venu
c'est un j'ai j'ai j'ai souvent
participé à des à des dialogue
médiatique notamment avec Gill guepel je
vous le dis amicalement et c'est pour
moi un grand plaisir à titre amical
aussi de le recevoir ici dans cette
institution la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'Assemblée nationale qui
a grand besoin de vos
lumières merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président et Cher Jean-Louis mesdames et
messieur c'est un très grand honneur
pour moi de d'échanger quelques quelques
réflexions avec vous
dans un moment où précisément le face à
l'incertitude notamment des états il me
semble que les instances comme la
représentation nationale d'une part et
l'Université de l'autre sont
particulièrement fondé à s'exprimer à
réfléchir ensemble
puisque au fond il y a pas pour
l'instant de solution qui semble
s'imposer comme vous venez de le dire
monsieur le Président alors la question
qu'il faut que je vous pose c'est de
combien de temps est-ce que je dispose
puisque je suis habitué à enfin j'étais
habitué à tenir un amphi à Science Po
pendant 2 heur sans qu'une mouche ne
vole mais ça ça fait partie du temps
révolu je vous imagine vous vous nvez
plus besoin pas besoin passer un examen
donc vous allez
m'interrome je fais taire les
journalistes généralement donc dites-moi
précis vous faites une introduction de
combien de temps après de un quart
d'heure 15 20 minutes bon allez
donnez-moi quand même 20 minutes 10 par
question ensuite chaque un représentant
de chaque groupe très bien va vous poser
une question pour de sur 2 minutes et
demi et vous allez essayer de lui
répondre dans le même lapse de temps
comme ça vous répondrez successivement à
toutes les groupes donc vous ne vous
inquiétez pas si vous ne dites pas
quelque chose d'important dans votre
introduction vous avez les cordes de
rappel à tout moment d'ord merci de
cette feuille de route comme on dit au
Moyen-Orient mais c'est une région où on
les respecte pas donc je vais essayer
d'être beaucoup ess de Pai voilà
beaucoup plus oui oui espérons alors euh
donc c'est un exposé en deux parties
donc toujours à Science Po donc la
nature du problème et les perspectives
som abonnés au même sens oui voilà c'est
terrible ou voilà oui c'est ou voilà ça
ça sera pour la fin quelques remarques
sur l'état de l'université aujourd'hui
si vous me permettez et V incitation à
ce que la représentation nationale se
penche sur l'état
l'université alors la nature du problème
auquel le monde est confronté euh le
concept entre guillemets de frérochisme
et autres bon je vais simple je vais
essayer de vous présenter l'analyse que
je fais à ce jour elle sera
peut-être différente demain puisque on
est on a chaque à chaque instant quand
on suit près les sites spécialisés des
informations nouvelles qui apparaissent
et qui permettent de remettre les choses
en perspective on remet ça sur le
chantier en tout le temps euh de de la
situation euh de ces de son origine
puisque c'est c'était là l'une de vos
questions et de ses développements
actuels euh je vais peut-être commencer
en d'un mot par les développements
actuels qui font aussi référence au vos
interrogations d'aujourd'hui et d'autres
que fameuses que vous avez fait
récemment sur la politique de Monsieur
netanahou et sur l'action volontaire il
me semble que la volonté tout à fait
explicite euh de de l'État d'Israël
aujourd'hui et de son premier ministre
c'est de détruire la ce qu'on pourrait
appeler c'est bien plus compliqué la
branche militaire de Hamas à Gaza euh ce
qu'on met dans ce syntag on en discutera
après mais à mon sens ils ne vont pas
s'arrêter tant qu'ils ne seront pas
arrivés à ce qu'ils estime être ce but
euh alors ça va poser toutes sortes de
questions de pression diverse la
communauté internationale liée à la aux
victimes civiles bien sûr euh mais je ne
vois pas
euh Israël et cet Israël mais Israël en
général s'arrêter euh avant d'avoir
atteint ce but car sans
cela le sentiment serait qu'Israël a
perdu euh et que le je n'ose pas dire
l'affront mais le l'horreur enfin
appelez ça comme vous voulez le si s'est
passé le le 11 septembre les 1400
victimes les 225 150 otages et la la
diffusion des images partout dans le
monde dans les télévisions on ne voit
que la version floutée sur les réseaux
sociaux du du monde entier on en voit
beaucoup plus et c'est effectivement
terrifiant euh cela n'a pas été d'une
certaine manière je nose pas dire lavé
mais euh quelque chose n'a pas été fait
en en contrepartie euh qui soit euh d'un
impact supérieur je ne sais pas si
j'arriis à bien m'exprimer parce que ce
sont des ce sont bien sûr des notions
qui sont très chargés émotionnellement
politiquement mais j'essaie de rester
aussi analytique que le que possible et
je crois que ça c'est un c'est c'est ce
qu'il faut comprendre que en tout cas la
politique israélienne aujourd'hui
l'armée euh avance apparemment beaucoup
plus vite que prévu le nombre de morts
israéliens est très faible au-dessous
sous des prévisions et la stratégie
actuelle stratégie d'encerclement à
gazanord disons des infrastructures du
Hamas qui sont effectivement situés dans
cette partie de la bande dans quelle
mesure est-ce que ils vont parvenir
parvenir à leur fin quelle sera la
gestion l'utilisation des otages
éventuels comme boucliers humain je n'en
sais rien mais en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on peut dire de la volonté
israélienne aujourd'hui ce pourquoi à ce
stade stade je vois très mal celle-ci
accepter quel que cessé le feu que ce
soit car ce serait perçu comme entériner
la défaite d'Israël une défaite qui est
très importante du point de vue
israélien parce qu'il s'agit d'un enjeu
selon ses dirigeants existentiels et
d'autre part pour la perpétuation même
de la capacité d'Israël à continuer le
processus qui a été engagé dans ce qu'on
a appelé le pacte d'Abraham puisqu'il
dépend principalement de la crédibilité
militaire d'Israël puisque dans le pacte
d'Abraham Israël fournit en grande
partie aux gouvernements arabes
signataires des moyens militaires au
Maroc pour lutter contre l'Algérie aux
Émirats pour lutter contre pour prévenir
les attaques iraniennes et cetera et le
déclenchement de la
guerre les phénomènes du 7
octobre intervient dans des temporalités
diverses on vaevenir venir on est en
train d'un petit peu d'arriver à
éclaircir euh le le processus pour
l'instant de manière encore hypothétique
mais on arrive à une reconstruction sur
lequ dansquel il manque des des pièces
au puzzle mais qui me semble
intéressante donc ça en terme très très
immédiat euh le 7 octobre ça vient après
le 2 octobre et le 26 septembre ça je ne
vous apprends rien euh qui était
respectivement les visites deux
premières visites officielles de
ministre israéliens l'Arabie Saoudite et
il me semble que cette coïncidence n'est
pas du tout fortuite car si l'Arabie
Saoudite pouvait disposer de
l'équivalent du dô de fer israélien ou
d'autres structures aujourd'hui plus
performantes semble-t-il que font safran
et autres qui le lui permettrai d'être à
l'abri des tirs de missilees envoyés par
quand des proxies comme on dit en
français euh mais mandataire n'est pas
une traduction terrible euh de de l'Iran
sur son territoire les Routis yéménites
peuvent tirer des missiles sur
l'aéroport de Riad s'en sont pas privés
le Hezbollah iraakien qui est un un
agent de l'Iran peut tirer depuis le
territoire iraakien des missiles pour
détruire les terminaux pétroliers ça a
été fait à robar pendant 2 jours il y a
il y a 2 ans ou 1 an et demi je me
souviens bien
donc tout ça évidemment ça facilite
énormément la main
de l'Arabie dans son bras de fer si vous
me pardonnez cette métaphore un peu
oiseuse face à l'Iran ça c'est un enjeu
extrêmement important donc pour l'Iran
il est vital qu'il n'y ait pas de
rapprochement saoudo-israélien quelquen
soit les modalités je ne pense pas que
l'Arabie était disposé à se mettre à la
norme des accords
d'Abraham les saoudiens et ceux à qui
j'ai parlé en plus récemment continuait
à insister sur la possibilité d'un
rapprochement avec Israël en insistant
sur quelque chose que les accords
d'Abraham avait rangé comme la poussière
sous le tapis c'est-à-dire les droits
des Palestiniens et l'analyse globale
que je fais de la situation actuelle
c'est que tout ce que toute la dynamique
que les accords d'Abraham ont voulu
mettre en œuvre c'est-à-dire créer une
prospérité économique avec des joint
ventures entre la startup nation et puis
le capital des pétrod dollars si vous
voulez qui peut effectivement créer un
processus vertueux qui tire par le haut
y compris les Arabes israéliens voir la
sisjordanie dans une certaine mesure a
complètement laissé Gaza de côté la
poudrière de Gaza qui a été finalement
considérée comme quelque chose qu'on
pouvait gérer y compris par Monsieur
netanahou lorsque que il favorisait le
l'avion qatari qui chaque mois arrivait
avec 10 millions de dollars en liquide à
l'aéroport bengouron qui était escorté
par le mossade jusqu'à la barrière des
Res puis par les services secrets
égyptiens jusqu'au centre nerveux du
Hamas que les Israéliens veulent en ce
moment
détruire et qui permettait de distribuer
de bien sûr de payer les salaires et
cetera mais aussi de fournir au Hamas
des frais de dossier et euh donc euh
c'est C si vous voulez cette situation
euh qui a été euh situation où Gaza
était une sorte de cocote minute
explosive euh mais où on euh on
utilisait des des des placebos ou une ou
une médecine symptommatique plutôt
qu'éthologique si vous préférez euh à
euh élimpensé des des accords des
accords d'Abraham et euh or c'est
aujourd'hui ce à quoi nous sommes
confronté c'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut
plus se le permettre
euh parce que ça la cocote minute si
j'ose dire encore une fois a fini par
exploser alors euh le
euh la situation à Gaza tout le monde
vous la connaissez je pas besoin de la
décrire j'y suis allé 5in ou six fois
euh notamment autrefois quand
pour rencontrer des des dirigeants du
Hamas au moment où ceci é dans une
position négociatrice plus importante
qu'aujourd'hui et où ils étaient moins
totalement sous la coupe de l'Iran euh
le Hamas d'aujourd'hui n'est plus le
même exactement en tout cas dans ses
procè décisionnel et sa mise en œuvre
que celui que j'ai connu il y a 20 ans
10 ans et cetera et auquel je vais
rendre visite officieusement évidemment
je n'avais aucune qualité représentant
qui que ce soit sauf moi-même et encore
à le faire à l'époque alors je ai dit
donc ça commence le 7 octobre a lieu
après la visite des ministres israéliens
à à en Arabie Saoudite ça c'est très
important et c'est très important aussi
pour euh penser à
le la main iranienne dans cette
volontier iranienne dans cette affaire
euh elle intervient aussi enfin
l'ofensive intervient aussi donc 50 ans
exactement c'est un demi-siècle après le
6 d' octobre 73 dans l'imaginaire mais
pour les très jeunes je ne sais pas
c'est plutôt pour 20ans comme moi euh le
c'est la revanche arabe à la
l'humiliation de la guerre des 6 jours
de juin 67 c'est l'initiative l'occasion
une fête religieuse qui pour qui baisse
la vigilance des juifs et des Israéliens
et là c'était le matin du shabbat
c'était une une fête juive et cetera un
peu selon le même le même principe donc
qui s'inscrit dans une geste globale de
la euh disons de la capacité arabe à
lutter contre la suprématie israélienne
donc ça ça se veut récupérer quelque
chose d'important même si la guerre
d'Octobre militairement a été gagnée par
Israël par la contreoffensive grâce au
pont aérien américain des termes qui se
reproduisent un peu aujourd'hui hein il
faut bien voir ça mais néanmoins qui a
été symboliquement et politiquement
gagné par le monde le monde arabe
puisque c'est ce qui a permis au roi
feissal d'Arabie Saoudite de faire
l'embargo et donc de faire du pétrole
une arme politique ce qui n'était pas le
cas auparavant donc ça si vous voulez
tout ça c'est intéressant parce que ça
rappelle aussi les les termes du du
conflit et qui qui font que on va boir
que
les les
euh les pays du golf qui pour l'instant
sont un semblent un peu en arrière de la
main sont probablement ceux qui à mon
sens ça sera pour la deuxième partie
tout à l'heure détiennent une partie non
négligeable de l' près et me semble-t-il
en en coopération avec les pays
européens de l'espace
euroméditerranéen alors euh trè élément
c'est le
euh c'est la la la ressemblance avec le
11 septembre j'ai très tôt appelé ça le
11 septembre d'Israël puisque ça exposé
Israël comme les États-Unis en 2001
comme un colosse au pied d'argile
et donc y a pas d'invincibilité et ça
bien sûr c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important symboliquement
puisque Israël tient face à l'hostilité
de ses voisins grâce à sa réputation d'
civilité militaire et c'est ça qui lui a
permis justement de faire les c'est sur
cette base ce que s'est construit le
deal si j'ose dire des accords d'Abraham
or là c'est c'est écorché si j'ose dire
c ébranlé et c'est pourquoi dans la
mentalité politique israélienne
aujourd'hui il est absolument
indispensable de détruire ce qui est
identifié comme la cause c'est-à-dire ce
qu'ils ont appelé la branche militaire
du Hamas eux-mêmes ont bien circonscrit
les choses il s'agit pas de détruire le
Liban il s'agit pas de je sais pas on
mentionné tout à l'heure qu'il avait nan
Ava dit qu'il allait aplatir le Liban il
a dit ça oui ah oui ah mais en cas
d'attaque ou d'accord ou oui parce que
ça c'est peut-être un peu au-dessus de
ses forces actuelles je
pense oui mais
euh mais le donc j'ai pas remarqué ça
j'ai pas relevé et donc ça c'est un
c'est un enjeu très très important dans
le terme la symbolique politique alors
alors maintenant comment est-ce que ça a
été déclenché et ça ça fait l'objet de
toutes sortes
d'interrogation j'ai écouté longuement
le discours de Hassan Nasrallah la
semaine dernière en arabe je ne dis pas
en direct par que ça avait été
certainement enregistré à l'avance pour
éviter que je ne sais quel algorithme
israélien envoie une missile sur
l'endroit pr la chaise précise où il
était assise mais en tout cas dans le
moment où il a été diffusé avec les la
mise en scène un abatillet au Sud Liban
à berou sud des foules qui agitai des
drapeaux et j'aiété très frappé par le
fait qu'il insistait sur que c'était une
décision purement
palestinienne que ni l'Iran ni le
Hezbollah n'était averti que même Hamas
a dans les hôtels luxueux de
Doha monsieur Han et Khaled mchal et les
autres avait la moindre idée euh alors
le fait qu'il le dise avec tant
d'insistance ne ne prédispose pas à à
croire la véracité de son propos
évidemment
mais euh et ce discours a été mis un peu
sur la touche parce que tout le monde
s'attendait euh toutes les rédactions
mais on m'avait mis en alerte pu que je
suis une sorte de membrane médiatique si
vous oui on peut dire ça oui la Gren oui
on peut dire la grenau pas d'illusion
là-dessus euh en alerte et puis j'ai
reçu truc c'est pas la peine de venir
vous dérangez pas vous dérange pas il
n'a rien annoncé euh il a si il a
annoncé quelque chose très important
d'abord que il ne il ne risque il
n'allait pas se risquer dans une
opération militaire puisque le Hezbollah
a la mémoire de ce qu'on appelle la
guerre des 33 jours de 2006 où ils ont
pris une initiative sont allés enlever
des soldats israéliens ensuite ils ont
euh enliser Israël euh dans son
offensive à travers les tunnels et
cetera ça et le Hezbollah est a été à ce
moment-là le héros de la rue arabe
c'était déjà une préfiguration de
l'Alliance fréros chiite et euh et ce
qui s'est passé là encore c'est que la
seule voix arabe qui était qui est
audible aujourd'hui et qui était audible
de Casablanca jusqu'à a finin fond de
l'Arabie Saoudite ou du Yémen c'est
celle d'un chiit libanais il n'y a pas
d'autre voie aujourd'hui que celle de
nasrala qui puisse avoir le même impact
ce qui est très très important et très
intéressant parce que parce que ce qu'il
dit
euh est dicté par théran alors il
s'exprime avec beaucoup d'éloquence en
arabe il est c'est rameni par l' arabe
il a traduit de livres de SAET C en
persant du l'ID l'idéologue des frères
musulman mais avec un fort accent
iranien alors que là il s'exprimait
d'une manière assez méliflu avec une
grammaire simplifié pour le et mais en
fait des vocabulaires du vocabulaire
très très sophistiqué très politiqu donc
il était parfaitement audible d'un bout
à l'autre du du monde arabe et d'une
certaine manière il posait comme norme
de du discours arabe qui se tient
aujourd'hui et qui visait les peuples et
non pas les chefs d'État quelque chose
qui était un script rédigé à terant ce
qui n'est
pas pas nul c'est un rapport de force
très important bon mais ça pour savoir
ce genre de chose il va faire étudier
l'arabe et comme c'est en détruit dans
notre université il y en a plus pour
longtemps donc quebollah peut venir
tranquille alors ça c'est un élément ce
qu'il a annoncé c'est donc il ne voulait
pas engager le hzbollah parce que pour
lui pour son compte pour le contrôle
iranien du Liban ça aurait risqué d'êre
une catastrophe la population excéder se
retournant contre le Hezbollah donc pour
des raisons intérieures je pense qu'il
n'a pas c'est c'est l'une des raisonss
alors et l'autre élément et surtout il a
dit on n pas même pas peur je traduit
approximativement enfin quand on le
comment s'appelle ce Gérald Ford en face
de soi non pas le vrai gerérald Ford
dont on sait qu'il ne pouvait pas walk
same time c'està dire marché du
chewingom même si je sais queassemblé
tweet en anglais maintenant je vais
traduire enfin certains
députésché du cheungum et marché en même
temps merci une phrase du président
Johnson voilà c'est ça oui et donc le on
espère que ce porteavion peut fois
flotter et envoyer des enfin bon mais il
y a le D qui est venu le renforc
oui mais il est plus petit oui et
surtout et le sous-marin nucléaire que
qui s qui a Fleuré dans le canal de suè
et qu'on a bien pu photographier donc le
il est clair que ça a été la première
décision américaine c'est d'envoyer le
groupe aéronaval si jamais le Hezbollah
avait fait quoi que ce soit ça veut dire
immédiatement une attaque américaine
donc je crois que là les les enjeux
étaient très clairs et l'Iran ne pouvait
pas se permettre l'escalade alors
maintenant
euh ce cette affaire est étonnante parce
que il semble que la franchissement de
la frontière le 7 octobre est dépassé
les espérances les plus folles de ceux
qui l'avaient mise en œuvre à tel point
que maintenant on a enfin dans les
dernières jusà ce matin j'aiess de SCER
pour passer mon examen peuresser de lire
de plus up to date pour vous le
il y a 3000 personnes qui ont qui ont
traversé et les 3000 nétaient pas tous
le hamass c'està-dire que quand ça a été
ouvert les prontaliers se sont rués
derrière selon un peu un mode qui est
celui de la Razia il faut bien voir que
c'est quelque chose qui est très présent
dans l'imaginaire religieux musulman et
le 11 septembre en arabe s'appelle al
Raz mubarakatetin c'est-à-dire la double
radia bénie il y a un duel en arabe
comme en grec ancien et ça c'est une
radia d'une certaine manre c'est on
arrive on prend on tue le plus de gens
possible dans le passé on prenait les
femmes pour les mettre dans les harem et
onit les enfants pour en faire des
musulmans là c'est pour en faire des
otages pas seulement les femmes mais
tous les gens qui étaient disponibles
d'une manière assez irrationnelle qui
fait que d'une certaine façon
aujourd'hui la masse des otages à gérer
est un problème pour ceux qui les
détiennent et ça pose aussi un très gros
problème au Qatar qui a été érigé ou
s'est érigé en intermédiaire parce que
d'une certaine elle manière il a la
corresponsabilité de la sûreté des
otages ce qui pour les otages est une
forme d'assurance mais dans
la en fonction des aléas des
bombardements et aujourd'hui donc
personne ne peut dire Grand- chose
alors donc ça ça donne le sentiment que
l'opération a en tout cas une fois la
frontière franchie échappé à ces
concepteurs quels qu'il soit alors quels
sont les concepteurs euh il me semble
impensable que moi j'ai traversé cette
frontière je sais pas 5 six fois à peu
près et déjà il y a un certain temps euh
avec des champs labourés des senseurs
partout euh des des miradors
électroniques il me semble impossible
que le garagiste du ramas avec sa sa
pince et sa clé à molette et pu
désactiver tout ça il y a eu 29 passages
euh donc c'est quand même c'est quelque
chose de gigantesque il y a eu des
actions coordonnées euh aérienne
maritime enfin c'était ça n'est pas
possible ça et effectivement alors les
sources qu'on a aujourd'hui viennent
d'Irak un certain nombre de gens qui
sont dans la
mouvance pro-iranienne en Irak ce qu'on
appelle has shabi les milices de la
mobilisation populaire ont parlit parce
que bon l'Irak est un pays compliqué où
le le le les limite entre la corruption
et l'engagement idéologique est parfois
un peu faible ce qui permet d'avoir si
on a un peu de cach quelques
informations et j'ai lu ça don je vous
renvoie au site al monitor qui mon avis
est ce que enfin ce qui me semble le
mieux j'ai a collaboré c'est pas pour ça
que je payant si je comprends bien non
non mais non celui-ci est gratuit il est
gratuit tu sais on peut av pardon vous
savez on peut avoir un site gratuit mais
il y a des machin d'autres manières de
se faire payer ailleurs Dieu seul conna
connaîtra les et donc qui indique
effectivement que ce qui a sur pris
l'establishement iranien
et du Hezbollah c'est le le jour du
déclenchement maintenant ditons en
revanche la
préparation il a été attesté que ça fait
15 à 16 mois que aussi bien au Liban que
dans les zones chies d'Irak les des
exercices des drills j'ai ça en anglais
de préparation avait été effectué parce
qu' il est impensable que cette
coordination est été décidé par un type
de toi tu vas là toi tu vas ici donc ça
c'est tout à fait euh à écarter euh donc
on peut penser que c'est une opération
qui a été montée alors moi je lis aussi
dans la je lisais dans la presse dans
les sites arabes du dub libanais
du Hamas et autres des descriptions de
la situation en en Israël qui était
chaque jour sous netanou la divine
surprise c'est-à-dire les les colons la
la la RUP future à l'intérieur du pays
la voilà la la fibre nationale Israël
est une euh la C c'est c'est pas comme
l'Assemblée nationale enfin dans la
vision peut-être trop idéalisée que j'en
ai ou il passe leur temps à s'insulter
et cetera mais au moment où où il faut
ver front il ver front il faire front
voilà oui c'est bon j'espère il contribu
tout à l'heure d' être démenti dans ma
vision irénique ici c'est un oui parce
qu'il y a un président qui est
oui B d'accord habil et euh et donc
le là les réservistes qui ne faisait
plus il refusaient de faire leur période
ça ça ça a été perçu comme une
opportunité en or qui ne se reproduirait
jamais ça à mon avis c'était très
présent qu'il allait il c'était le
moment d'attaquer c'était le moment de
d'en finir avec le processus de
processus d'Abraham ou en tout cas de le
faire dérailler signific tivement
maintenant ce qu'on ne sait pas
précisément c'est le choix du jour du
déclenchement enfin en tout cas pour moi
je ne sais pas mais
et que l'infrastructure a été mise en
place en avant et que ce soit le travail
de la brigade cots des Gardiens de la
révolution que ce soit le Lake Postume
de Monsieur Soleimani dont la vengeance
pour l'Iran est un enjeu majeur aussi si
j'ose dire presque aussi fort que pour
Israël de venger les 1400 victimes si
vousz ça a été pour eux un choc
absolument épouvantable vous pouvez
acheter des vêtements de la vaisselle
en les figie de soleimman c'est c'est
une sorte de Dieu vivant et et donc
c'est
oui un dieu est oui ça il est mort vous
avez raison oui et donc le enfin il
n'est pas plus mort parce après sa mort
il est devenu un dieu vivant faire
théologie dans cette enceinte laïqueon
et euh et donc ça c'est je je crois que
c'est ce sont les les ce sont les
éléments de connaissance qu'on a
aujourd'hui s'y ajoute dans le même
ordre de de questionnement la fameuse
attaque de l'hôpital elahli et non pas
Halali comme le disait la la pressevec
le Hal alahli veut dire national et un
hôpital géré par des des
religieux protestants euh qui et s'est
produite opportunément au moment où le
malheureux Joe Biden était dans l'avion
pour venir euh sur place et devait
rencontrer les Israéliens les Arabes ce
qui fait que on a imputé ça un
bombardement israélien Mahmoud Abbas euh
a été essayer de parler deun manière
respectueuse et rester chez lui et du
coup Biden n' pu voir que que les
Israéliens ce qui évidemment pour la
propagande iranienne était formidable
parce que il était clair que Biden ne
venait que pour soutenir Israël et se
moquer des Arabes euh on a découvert
ensuite que c'est un des une
tiré par le Djihad islamique palestinien
qui est totalement
le l'agent iranien
depuis très longtemps fondé par
faaki et qui avait dédié son premier
livre au deux imam du siècle l'imam
Hassan El Bana fondateur des Frères et
l'imam romini donc c'est là c'est le
kéigme fondateur de du frèochéisme si
vous voulez
et est-ce que la roquette qui est tombée
sur l'
est tombé par erreur est-ce que on avait
pas mis trop de poudre dedans pour
qu'elle tombe à cet endroit-là de
manière à faire dérailler la visite de
Biden les historiens le sauront
peut-être un jour mais enfin ça fait
partie du marge de la marge des des
possibles ce qui veut dire que on a face
à soi une opération qui a été euh à la
fois
euh préparé de très longues dates mais
dont le le le moment choisi euh semble
n'avoir pas
euh avoir peut-être été le fait de la
décision donc de celui qui est
aujourd'hui la bête noire d' israéliens
et qu'il recherche partout il s'appelle
Yahya sinoir qui est le plus haut
responsable du Hamas présent sur le
territoire de Gaza aujourd'hui avec le
fameux Mahamed
Daif surnommé ainsi car il faut dire
haute en arabe il était toujours invité
chez les gens il n' jamais de domicile
fixe
SDF et SDF et donc
le euh voilà à peu près la situation
telle que je peux donner quelques
éléments de d'analyse aujourd'hui euh et
donc j'ai répondu à la question LAX
frochit il se manifeste ainsi et il se
manif alors il est il avait justement
été très très entamé par les par la
dynamique des accords d'Abraham qui
était tellement dynamique que finalement
même le Qatar qui était l'un des
soutiens de l'X frér
chit avait s'en était retiré et avait
c'était dit finalement il y a des
opportunités pour le Qatar à sinon
participer aux accords d'Abraham en tout
cas sinscrire dans cette dynamique le
Qatar ayant un bureau de liaison avec
Israël depuis très longtemps qui est
épisodiquement fermé mais il y a
quelqu'un d'autre qui vient qui n'a pas
le statut enfin c'est le et cet axochit
il y avait donc l'Iran les Frères
musulmans le Qatar les finançant en
grande partie et la Turquie d'Erdogan
or Erdogan s'était mis pas mal en
retrait de cet acte aussi cet axe aussi
puisque la crise économique est telle en
Turquie qu'il a besoin des pétrrodllars
saoudiens et émiratis en particulier
lesquels détestent les Frères musulmans
et la contrepartie des pé ar c'était que
les frères égyptiens par exemple ne
puissent plus s'exprimer en Turquie il
les a fait partir ils sont tous venus en
Europe le paradis des Frères musulmans
c'est l'Union européenne comme vous le
savez qui subventionne largement leurs
multiples activités y compris des
universitaires qui leur sont liés qui
sont leur proxies au détriment de votre
serviteur par exemple et euh et donc
aujourd'hui Erdogan a fait une volle de
face euh qui je crois va encore lui avir
quelquesavan de de ce côté-ci de de de
l'Europe et des États-Unis puisque il a
reçu le ministre israélien pardon pas du
tout israélien iranien des Affaires
étrangères a fait un discours très très
virulent
anti-israélien et d'une certaine manière
c'est c'est'est rapproché de cet acte
pourquoi euh et j'en termine par là
avant de brièvement au deuxième point
puisque
oui oui bien sûr je je euh parce que
il il il considère qu'il y a pour lui
une opportunité de challenger mot
français le le leadership égal d'autre m
français de Mohamed Ben Salman sur
l'islam sunit il avait déjà fait ça au
moment de la pandémie quand Mohamed Ben
Salman en bon élève de l'OMS avait fait
un pèlerinage avec un musulman
représentant métonymique ou sinecdotial
un un musulman représentant chaque pays
du monde tous les 100 m avec un masque
sanitaire et un autour de lui donc où
était la photo opportunity avec 3
millions de musulmans derrièreil donc ça
ne marchait pas et c'est ce momentlà
qu'Erdogan a réislamisé saintesophie
avec son imam en chef Ali herbach qui
brandissait le sabre en disant et je
crois que pour Erdogan il y a une
opportunité là qui est en train de se
présenter ce qui fait qu'entre du coup
il a il a perdu tout le rôle médiateur
qu'il avait essayé de construire
auparavant un mot simplement sur la
sortie de conflit alors
euh il me semble que la sortie de
conflit j'ai déjà répondu à la question
enfin de ce que je pouvais dire sur les
tanaho m et cetera je crois que la
solution elle est très largement entre
les mains des pays du golf qui ont le
porte-monnaie et qui ont déjà commencé à
faire une diplomatie du chéquier euh
dont je dirais pas qu'elle est
coordonnée avec les Israéliens mais qui
en tout cas euh à vocation à être perçu
comme une option
palestinienne par la les arabes en
général ça a été le le largage
d'équipement hospitalier par les
jordanien dans la partie sud de Gaza qui
est plus ou moins off limits de
l'offensive israélienne et l'arrivée
prochaine d'un hôpital de campagne
émirati les euh les Saoudiens là-dessus
ont une politique qui est toujours très
très explicite toujours la même j'en ai
parlé avec avec le prince lui-même au
mois de juin est venu en France je l'ai
vu qu'tait à loufciienne m' invité à
dîner et
le
c'est aucun pas de souci pour le
rapprochement avec Israël à condition
que les droits des Palestiniens soient
respectés alors tout ce qu'on ce qu'on
met dans cette formule évidemment
peut-être compliqué mais ça n'est pas
quelque chose qui était dans le
préambule des des accords d'Abraham en
tout cas pas de cette manière-là et euh
je crois que c'est c'est ce que vont
certainement jouer euh en particulier
les Saoudiens puisque en fait c'est ils
sont la clé de tout et euh l'une des
l'une des hypothèses non négligeables de
du la date du déclenchement c'est que
c'est précisément après la visite des
ministres Israëli en Arab Sai et surtout
pour ne pour empêcher ce processus très
qui estit ment au détriment de l'Iran de
se manifester deuxième point et pour
donner un tout petit peu d'espoir doncil
fallait attendre mais il va arriver il
me semble que le les
pays de l'ensemble euroméditerranéen ont
un rôle très important à jouer en
coordonnation avec ce que sera
l'initiative des pays du Golf puisque
contrairement aux Américains qui voit
tout ça de loin pour lesquels c'est un
enjeu de politique extérieure même si
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président les manifestations à
l'université Colombia aujourd'hui dirigé
par quelqu'un qui une collègue qui est
également une ami à moi qui est
d'origine égyptienne et qui était
vice-gouverneur de la Banque
d'Angleterre puis patronne de LSI ce qui
a suscité lire d'ailleurs d'un certain
nombre de manifestants
euh même si on voit qu'à la à
l'intérieur de des États-Unis aussi se
manifeste aujourd'hui des voix
propalestiniennes qu'on éétait pas
habitué à entendre je pense à votre
collègue Rachida t la seule
palestino-américaine démocrate du
Michigan qui a fait une déclaration très
empreinte d'émotions vous l'AVE
peut-être vu la chambre euh la Chambre
des Représentants euh hier je crois donc
mais pour nous en tout cas beaucoup plus
qu'aux États-Unis euh le conflit euh
fait partie de politique intérieure euh
nous l'avons vu et euh évidemment euh il
est très lié euh aux questions euh qui
traversent aussi votre éminente
assemblée euh les expressions de la
solidarité avec un camp ou ou l'autre
par diverses forces politiques font
parti d'enjeux que que nous devons gérer
on ne peut pas pour nous le le
Moyen-Orient et l'Afrique du Nord ne
font pas seulement partie de notre
politique extérieure c'est un enjeu de
de politique intérieure et le le
président de la République m'avait
confié un rapport sur ce sujet il y a
quelques moi j'étais allé dans les
quatre pays les plus exportateurs de
population d'origine musulmane en France
les trois du Maghreb et la Turquie et
dans quatre départements que j'avais
choisi comme étant particulièrement
représentatif de celui-ci ce rapport a
été lu avec intérêt mais évidemment
classé sans suite comme on pouvait s'y
attendre voilà merci monsieur le
Président et merci mesdames et messieurs
de votre écoute vos propos ne seront pas
classés sans suite je tiens à vous le
dire ici euh merci c'était des coups
d'éclairage extrêmement intéressant
maintenant je vais demander alors
au au représentants des groupes de
parler alors évidemment euh il ne s'agit
pas pour les uns ou pour les autres de
faire des déclarations euh de de de de
prise de position nous connaissons
chacun les positions ce que nous voulons
c'est amener monsieur kepppel à nous
donner euh à répondre à notre curiosité
et à nous donner plus d'informations et
plus d'éclaircissement qu' N a donné
pourtant nous avons une moisson
abondante qui nous a été livrée le
premier intervenir c'est pour le groupe
en naissance Monsieur
guillomar Merci monsieur le Président
minut et demi a pas plus je vais faire
de mon mieux merci monsieur le Président
merci au professeur Kepel de partager
avec nous son son expertise très utile
pour appréhender la la situation en
particulier en cette période où nous
voyons on fleurir un peu des experts de
pacoti c'est intéressant d'avoir un vrai
spécialiste pour nous expliquer son son
point de vue un mois s'est écoulé depuis
l'attentat du groupe terroriste Hamas
qui a aé la vie vous l'avez rappelé à
1400 personnes majoritairement des des
civils dont 40 de nos compatriotes
français vous l'avez rappelé aussi des
des otages sont encore détenus et pour
répondre à cette attaque et démanteler
le Hamas Israël initié l'opération glve
de fer
bien que le droit d'Israël à se défendre
face aux atrocités qu'elle subit est
incontestable et même souhaitable le
lourd bilan humain avec plusieurs
milliers de de victimes selon le
Pentagone attise le l'hostilité contre
Israël cette hostilité est alimentée en
premier lieu par l'Iran vous l'avez
également souligné l'attaque du 7
octobre a d'ailleurs selon vous mis en
attente et non pas arrêté définitivement
le rapprochement entre certains pays
arabes comme l'Arabie Saoudite et Israël
ce qui est une victoire pour le Hamas et
l'Iran mais peut-être que vous pourriez
nous dire quelles sont les étapes qui
pourraient être attendu pour la reprise
de de ce processus le déploiement
significatif de la puissance militaire
des États-Unis dans la région avec
notamment deux pores-avion et des des
sous-marins vous l'évoquiez je crois
dans un interview ou un article a
jusqu'à présent permis de de contenir en
tout cas c'est c'est le ce que je
comprends le risque d'escalè du conf
conflit dans dans dans la région
néanmoins selon vous est-ce que
l'absence d'une trêve humanitaire
conjuguait l'augmentation des victimes
civile pour être de nature à précipiter
la région dans un embrasement plus vaste
et quelles hypothèses pouvons-nous faire
sur cette embrasement que tout le monde
redoute quelle pourrait être selon vous
la première étape de cet embrasement et
puis une dernière question très simple
je le conçois quelle doit être selon
vous la position que doit adopter la
France et la communauté internationale
tion à ce stade du conflit pour amorcer
une acalmie ou mieux un apaisement merci
ça c'est la preuve qu'il est plus facile
de poser des questions en 2 minutes que
d'y répondre mais cherchil Keppel nous
comptons sur vous je vais m'efforcer
monsieur le Président de ne pas donner
dans la caricature de l'université je
représente je suis en train de ne plus
représenter euh alors
euh le
euh
votre bon je prière partie de votre de
votre intervention présente un un un
bilan sur lequel je n'ai nai rien à dire
euh le en effet alors le la venue des
enfin le déploiement militaire
américain est une est un élément
d'indication qu' il y a un seuil
militaire qui ne peut pas franchir pour
nous consoler nous avons envoyé le
tonner le le porte-avion lui est à la
réparation donc ça dit aussi beaucoup de
choses sur ce qu'est la situation actuel
les Anglais ont un porteavion mais il
n'y a que H aéronefs dessus je crois
d'après ce que j'ai compris donc euh ça
remet un peu les choses en place et
heureusement que les Chinois n'ont pas
encore envoyé les leurs donc ça pose la
question plus large de d'une anisme
politique et militaire de l'Europe
euh donc dans cette perspective que
peut-on faire puisque les si j'ose dire
ce sont les hard facts euh alors
le comme je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
je crois que demain le le forum de Paris
pour la paix se réunit à
l'Élysée le il me semble que le bon il y
a tous les éléments
évidemment de le soutien humanitaire que
l'on peut mettre en œuvre aujourd'hui en
particulier faire tout ce que nous
pouvons pour venir au secours de nos de
nos compatriotes que ce soit les
binationaux qui ont été pris en
otage ceux qui qui sont dans une
situation traumatique en Israël ou ceux
qui sont également binationaux à à Gaza
et j'ai vu qu'une une évacuation avait
lieu je ne sais pas avec les agents
notamment du centre culturel que le
hamasaelait l'ambassade d' autrefois
quand j' mais euh le ainsi que le que
des des Palestiniens de nationalité
français française mais je crois que ça
c'est bien sûr c'est un enjeu un enjeu
très important
euh euh se se joindre certainement
aux aux initiatives qui sont prises par
par les États du golf et qui disposent
évidemment de moyens financiers plus
importants euh pour
euh faire en sorte que soutienneent le
euh des gens qui sont qui sont blessés
et qu'on favorise le T toute la
dimension humanitaire des choses plus
loin à ce stade là précisément je ne
vois pas ce qu'on peut faire sinon des
des parole veine parce que c'est ça
n'est pas pour faire plaisir à l'Union
européenne même la France que
l'offensive israélienne va s'arrêter on
peut faire un vux pieux mais je ne pense
pas que ce soit réaliste en revanche euh
il me semble que d'ors et déjà il faut
s'efforcer de penser à l'après euh
notamment avec une initiative commune à
l'espace euroméditerranéen et au pays de
la péninsule arabique seul à même de euh
de de de créer une une de recréer une
dynamique de paix à condition justement
que l'impensée des accords d'Abraham
soit pensé c'est-à-dire euh que la
question palestinienne soit posé et
alors je ne suis pas là pour non c'est
pas moi qui va si c'est la solution à
deux états est viable ou autre je ne
sais pas ce qui peut sortir du chapeau
mais en tout
cas je crois que tout ce qui la
différence entre deains et hier c'est
que on ne peut pas simplement évacuer
Gaza comme la poussière sous le tapis ou
le faire subventionné par le Qatar pour
pour que pour le calmer et distribuer
quelques prébandes par-ci par là voyz je
crois que ça c'est ça c'est c'est quand
même ce que les choses on j'étais
presque bon là vous avez été presque
vous avez été excellent et et et et et
presque court non c'est presque
bon j'avais bien compris je suis pasé
sur ce sur le reste mon cher ami pour le
rassemblement national c'est madame la
députée de la Somme Madame Y
mache merci monsieur le Président je ne
vous vois pas je suis là
attendez je vais me décaler un peu si
vous voulez merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Professeur Keppel euh
les circonstances de guerre hybrides
auxquelles nous assistons au Proche
Orient depuis le 7 octobre dernier sont
très inquiétantes la position de notre
groupe est très clair il affirme le
soutien du droit des Israéliens de se
défendre comme celui du droit des
Palestiniens de jouir d'un État
souverain les crimes et les violences
terribles liées à ce conflit sont
effrayants et beaucoup oup a été dit sur
le sujet je n'ai absolument pas le goût
d'insister sur ces faits et sur chaque
tragédie que représente la mort violente
d'un innocent à ce point profitant de
votre présence et de votre expertise
monsieur le prof interroger sur la
complexité de ce conflit c'est un fait
avéré que le Hamas est financé par une
part significative par le Qatar qu'une
partie de ses cadres s'exprime depuis ce
pays et que cette situation est pour le
moins inconfortable compte tenu des
liens que le Qatar entretient avec avec
nombre de pays occidentaux alors
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur le rôle
du Qatar qui d'un côté aide la France
pour rapatrier les ressortissants
français et de l'autre finance une
organisation terroriste permettant
d'attaquer Israël je vous
remercie c'est une question très
importante parce que vous avez parlé du
PCT d'Abraham et le Qatar est dans une
situation tout à fait différente et en
même temps il préfigure un peu ce que
pourrait pour faire le pacte d'Abraham
intermédiaire entre la Palestine et
cetera comment comment le Qatar peut-il
s'intégrer se se positionner par rapport
à ces vieux compétiteurs les Émirats
arabes unis l'Arabie Saoudite et
cetera merci Madame la député le le
Qatar en
effet a depuis très longtemps jouer un
rôle intermédiaire il y avait moi je
j'avais rencontré des Israéliens au
Qatar bien avant euh qu'il y ait une
formalisation des liens euh les dans les
colloques les il y avait il y avait
généralement des Israéliens qui n'avait
qui n'apparaissait même comme
généralement les Israéliens
apparaissaient comme américains si vous
voulez ils avaient un passeport
américain aussi et ça passait mais là
c'était euh x université de téaviv ça
sans que ce soit officiel c'était déjà
présent depuis longtemps mais euh ils
ont euh alors le Qatar euh accueille
aussi son territoire de nombreuses
universités américaines Georgetown un
certain nombre d'autres et
euh dépense comme vous savez beaucoup
d'argent euh aussi bien aux États-Unis
qu'en France et en Europe le Qatar gate
étant évidemment dans toutes les
mémoires
donc certains aussi s'interrogent sur
son financement de certains dirigeants
politiques de notre pays mais je ne vais
pas avancer sur ce sujet moi-même la
justice' en occupe le euh donc le
le Qatar néanmoins a une différence par
rapport à l'Arabie Saoudite et euh et au
et aux Émirats le kit étant plus
ambivalent c'est son soutien absolu au
Frères musulmans pourquoi le Qatar
a-t-il soutenu les Frères musulmans
depuis toujours c'est parce que le Qatar
est tout petit l'Arabie c'est un géant
et c'est un peu si vous voulez la
métaphore du Tigre et de l'éléphant de
qui était celle du du vietm c'est-à-dire
le tigre c'était à l'époque le
colonialiste français ou pardon
l'éléphantiste français ou l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est le pachiderme qui domine
la jungle à condition d'être à peu près
agile s'il n'est pas agile un des tigres
lui saute sur le dos déchire sa carapace
les mouches viennent pondre dedans il
tombent et le l'autre tigre en fait son
festin euh et euh le l'Arabie saoudite a
toujours eu des véléités de faire taire
le Qatar et de le
maintenir sous sa coupe
elgzira était l'un des moyens de lutter
contre cette cette cette force
saoudienne et le soutien au Frères
musulmans c'était l'occasion pour le
Qatar de disposer d'un réseau
international très important qui soit
compétiteur des des Saoudiens voyez qui
leur parce que les Saoudiens avaient un
réseau salafiste à l'époque que le
prince actuellement ne veut plus du tout
s'appuyer
là-dessus sans toutefois s'aliéner les
bénéfices qu'il tire de son euh
de sa fonction de de chef spirituel
enfin de chef matériel aussi de l'UMA
islamique si vous voulez de
d'organisateur du pèlerinage de des
servants des de lieux saints comme on
dit en arabe donc c'est là le c'est là
le le différentiel alors le Qatar
finance le Hamas oui mais comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure il l'a financé
avec la bénédiction de Bibi
netaniao quand quand il quand celui qui
celui qui organisait le la l'avion
l'avion du million enfin des 10 millions
de dollars chaque chaque mois c'était
Yosi Cohen chef du Mossa à l'époque à
qui on prêtait des des ambitions
politiques qui ne se sont pas pour
l'instant avéré
et et les qatari on beau jeu de répondre
mais oui on le faisait mais à la demande
des Israéliens voyez donc alors j'ai
bien entendu que un certain nombre
de vos collègues ont demandé qu'on
saisisse les biens du Qatar
euh en France je suis pas sûr que ce
soit une politique très réaliste par
alors on peut être pour ou contre la
politique du Qatar et elle a des
ambigués que j'ai moi-même souligné
plusieurs fois dans dans des écrits euh
aujourd'hui le Qatar est dans une
situation de pivotale si vous voulez
sans laquelle on ne peut pas fonctionner
et euh on ne peut pas
être on peut pas demander à tous les
tous les pays partenaires d'être
exactement sur la même position que que
nous le sommes sinon nous serions
supplémentaire si vous voulez et euh
c'est cela étant ça n'empêche pas de
mettre la pression sur le Qatar si vous
le souhaitez en ce moment mais ou dans
et les ambiguïés de sa politique mais il
vit de ça le Qatar partage par exemple
le plus gros jaisement gazier du monde
avec l'Iran que les Qataris appellent
North Dome et les Iraniens South Pars
c'est comme si vous aviez ce verre si
vous voulez donc Jean-Lou
BR moi j'ai des bulles si vousz d'accord
donc dans ce verre donc la métaphore ça
c'est le le champ gazier Jean bourlange
et l'Iran moi je suis le Qatar ça va ça
convient mais nous avons tous les deux
une paille simplement celle de l'Iran
est bouchée parce qu'il a les sanctions
internationales peut pas forer donc
c'est le Qatar qui for donc le niveau
des baisses pour les deux cette
métaphore du l'université quand même
c'est pas pour rien j'ai fait toutes ces
études mais le du coup le les vous savez
littéraire mais je vois une culture
s j'ai fait un bac a quand même j'ai eu
le bac parce que du premier coup par
qu'il avait les matths au rattrapage eu
le rattrapageurais jamais réussi mon et
donc secr un secret que je ne confie
qu'en fin de carrière et donc quand tout
est joué donc du coup il y a une y a une
très une très forte complémentarité avec
cliran quand le était sous boycotte de
ses voisins il passait par le l'espace
iranien l'espace aérien iranien voyez
entre 201 les Iraniens facturer ça assez
cher du reste
donc je ne pense aujourd'hui c'est un
acteur comme on ne doit pas dire dans
les dissertations à chiancep
incontournable voyez et de ce fait on on
peut vous êtes dans votre rô 6 minutes
vous avez 2 minutes en principe pardon
ah
B on est on on est sous le charme mais
mais bon d'accord bon bon obligé voilà
j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire je
c maintenant c'est Madame merc soué qui
va s'exprimer au nom de quel groupe la
fou qu'on lui connaitt elle est
fille ah pardon non c'est moi c'est moi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur kel
lors de la guerre de Gaza de 2014 vous
disiez sur France 24 plus Israël ré
excusez-moi j'ai président pis
répéterbres phrases que alors je disais
que lors de la guerre de Gaza de 2014
vous disiez sur France 24 plus Israël
réplique et plus le Hamas remporte une
victoire symbolique et politique vous
ajoutez que des images que les images
terribles des morts civiles Gazaoui
scandalisaient la communauté
internationale galvanisaient le Hamas et
le confortait dans son rôle de résistant
palestinien tandis qu'Israël accroissait
son isolement tout récemment Benon
Sanders un ancien soldat israélien qui a
participé à cette guerre est sorti du
silence Sanders se souvient avoir été
déployé pour avec son unité dans le nord
de l'enclave palestinienne pour aider à
localiser et détruire les tunnels du
Hamas il se souvient qu'on lui avait
certifié qu'il n'y avait plus de civil
et qu'il avait ensuite découvert des
cadavres et des personnes qui n'avaient
pas pu fuir il se souvient que son unité
avait dû se replier et que l'aviation
israélienne avait répliqué en rayant
pratiquement le quartier de la carte
Sanders s'est beaucoup interrogé sur le
sens de tout cela il se disait qu'en
éliminant le Hamas tous ces sacrifices
humains auraient valu la peine car ainsi
Israël aurait gagné en
sécurité mais l'histoire a montré que le
Hamas n'est pas mort alors Sanders a
compris que pour venir à bout du Hamas
ce ne sont pas des actions militaires
qu'il faut mais la création d'une
alternative et l'alternative dit-il
c'est la perspective d'indépendance pour
les Palestiniens c'est la fin de
l'occupation perpétuelle du territoire
palestinien or on n a jamais été aussi
loin vous l'avez dit vous-même sur
France info je vous cite monsieur
Netanyahou otage de ses ennuis
judiciaires a tout céd à son extrême
droite avec qui il a noué une alliance
en 2022 pour retrouver le pouvoir en
soutenant la colonisation à outoutrance
Francis Jordanie Sanders demande l'aide
de la communauté internationale pour
faire pression sur le gouvernement
netanyiaou il estime que si celui-ci ne
change pas d'approche non seulement
cette guerre continuera de multiplier
les morts tant du côté palestinien
qu'israélien mais qu'elle ne mettra pas
fin de manière décisive à la
terreur le président a pris l'initiative
d'organiser demain une conférence
humanitaire internationale pour la
population civile à Gaza mais nous
comprenons bien finalement que la
réponse ne peut se contenter d'être
humanitaire et qu'elle doit être
également politique comment le président
Macron pourrait-il selon vous faire de
cet événement un réel appui pour les
Israéliens et les Palestiniens qui
espèrent un avenir où chacun
s'épanouirait
enfin je vous
remercie répondez au nom de Monsieur
Sanders
oui je n'avais pas perçu le rôle aussi
important de Monsieur Sanders mais
écoutez je suis très heureux que de la
prendre de votre bouche le euh
euh pour euh la conférence sur la paix
pour le rôle
du de la France et de et du président de
la République mais il me semble
précisément que c'est en se projetant
sur cet après comme je l'ai mentionné
tout à l'heure qu'il y a une véritable
opportunité je crois que ce serait
illusoire de croire que nous pouvons
agir aujourd'hui si vous voulez j'ai
rappelé que le Charles de Gaulle était
la réparation en ce moment euh qu'est-ce
qui fait que les
États-Unis disposent d'un force de
pression et même eux n'ont pas
véritablement la
capacité de
limiter l'action américaine c'est qu'il
y a le gerérald Ford le disenhauer et le
sous-marin nucléaire qui sont à côté
et ça c'est en terme très très
réaliste que le que le Hamas soit T tou
jours là oui vous avez raison le le
Hamas est au départ un mouvement
national palestinien un mouvement
national palestinien islamiste et
d'ailleurs
que le les autorités israéliennes ont
ont dans dans depuis le début je ne dis
pas toujours favorisé mais considéré
comme un interlocuteur égal à l'OLP ne
serait-ce que parce que ça leur
permettait de minoriser l'OLP je si le
président me donne 2 secondes pourun S
souvenir de jeunesse quand j'étais en
Égypte dans les années 1980 merci euh
l'Égypte de récupérer le Sinaï donc on
allait se balader dans Sinaï c'était
merveilleux à l'époque et puis après il
fallait repasser le canal où il y av une
barge égyptienne qui faisait la navette
il y av pas tunel qui était toujours
cassé ou en retard et je me suis trouvé
coincé en Renant vers le CER avec le
chargé d'affair israélien et sa femme
qui était une juif de Sarcel je crois et
on attendait sans sécurité à l'époque
c'est tout à fait surprenant et puisand
ce que je que vous une thèse sur les
islamistes les Frères musulmans ah c'est
très passionnant nous en Israël ça nous
intéresse beaucoup on considère que les
Frères musulmans sont une une composante
essentielle de du peuple palestinen des
Palestiniens je disais du peuple et
d'emblé si vous voulez le un peu comme
certains en France aimaient tellement
l'Allemagne qui voulait en avoir deux le
les Israéliens ont joué si vous voulez
sur la sur sur sur la dualité et dans
dans la faire le Hamas a été aussi très
largement utilisé pour faire en sorte
que que l'OLP qui avait quand elle a
renoncé au au terrorisme
acquis un un grand renom international
du coup
soit soit dans une situation beaucoup
plus difficile ensuite aussi la victoire
du Hamas à Gaza en 20062007 et cetera
donc il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui dans cette circonstance
simplement le Hamas comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure brièvement a changé me
semble-t-il par rapport à celui que j'ai
connu et avec lequel il y avait un
certain nombre de contacts euh parce
qu'il est aujourd'hui très
largement dans les mains de l'Iran et
parce qu'aussi ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre est quelque chose qui aux yeux
de la communauté internationale disons
en tout cas au moins des États de
l'Union européenne dont nous faisons
partie
eu est une atrocité sur sur laquelle il
est impossible de
passer alors on peut répliquer que les
bombardements de l'armée israélienne sur
Gaza sont également une atrocité sur
laquelle il est impossible de passer euh
d'autres vous répondront à ce moment-là
que euh ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre
a fait l'objet d'une immense publicité
de la part de celà même qu' l' avait
commis et cetera donc moi je ne veux pas
arbitrer entre ça mais pour pour
m'intéresser à votre votre votre
question
prospective il me semble en fait en
effet que nous devons enfin la France
peut très très significativement comme
pays européens se positionner pour
l'après et effectivement faire de la
reconnaissance des droits du peuple
palestinien un élément constitutif
absolu de toute solution qui viendrait
ensuite sans C sans cela on aboutira à
ce à quoi ont abouti les accords
d'Abraham c'est-à-dire à l'explosion à
Gaza
don y compris avec sa monstruosité si
vous voulez dans un sens puis dans
l'autre voyez je ne sais pas si je peux
aller beaucoup plus loin dans la
prospective r elle serait ilra voilà et
le je me suis appuyé sur le président en
délayant un peu ma réponse comme ça il
m' empêcher donc vous ne délayez pas
vous développeer euh la parole
maintenant est à mot de Gatel pour le
modem madame la députée c'est à vous
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
merci pour l'organisation de cette
audition qui vient utilement conforter
les différents travaux que mène la
commission des affaires étrangères
depuis le 7 octobre et l'immense
tragédie à laquelle nous assistons
depuis lors et vous l'avez vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur
kepppel le le cette attaque s'inscrit
dans un contexte un contexte politique
et un contexte en lien avec les
différentes mesures décisions prises par
le gouvernement de Benjamin de Benjamin
netaniaahou même si aucune politique
aussi contesté et contestable soit-elle
ne peut justifier l'horreur du
terrorisme vous l'avez évoqué dans votre
introduction
liminaire la présence de la main
iranienne et l'instrumentalisation par
le Hamas l'instrumentalisation pardon du
Hamas par l'Islam
chiit et l'élément déclencheur que
peut-être a constitué le le la
normalisation des relations en cours
avec l'Arabie Saoudite et Israël et je
voulais vous poser la question des
conséquences sur les signataires de
l'accord d'Abraham au regard de l'effet
des sur l'opinion publique de la
tragédie en cours sous nos yeux à Gaza
et puis vous l'avez évoqué également ce
sont les perspectives les perspectives
vous avez vous n'avez pas formellement
parler de de l'Europe en tout cas de
certains pays européens je pense
évidemment à la France et le le rôle du
président de la République notamment
démontré lors de son sa visite dans la
région et de sa capacité à anouer un
certain nombre de de de dialogue de pont
avec un certain nombre d'États
extrêmement importants de la région et
puis peut-être également le Royaume-Uni
dans le cadre justement de ce que
pourrait être une initiative
Euroméditerranée que vous avez évoqué à
l'instant je vous
remercie ce que je voudrais ajouter ce
que dit ma ma collègue effectivement
Abraham le pacte d'Abraham avait un
grand avantage de rapprochement entre
Israël et les peuples arabes il avait
quand même un effet toxique extrêmement
comment peuple je ne sais pas
gouvernement certainement oui j'ai dit
euh peuple arabe c'est gouvernementou
gouvernement Arab oui oui absolument
vous avez tout à fait raison euh il
avait en revanche un effet toxique
évident c'est qu'il a été il était un
permis de d'agir absolument librement
donné à Monsieur netanahou dans la dans
la zone palestinienne en tout cas c'est
ainsi qu'il l'a interprété dit
maintenant j'ai les les Palestiniens
sont seuls je peux en faire ce que je
veux bon et ça a donné ça a contribué
quand même au résultat effrayant que
nous avons vu et est-ce que cette
justement est-ce que cette
responsabilité là euh les les les
peuples les gouvernements arabes modérés
peuvent s'en s'en saisir et refaire le
chemin inverse parce que malgré tout ils
ont agi avec un très grand cynisme dans
cette affaire vis-à-vis des
palestinien
euh un des éléments les plus frappants
qui nous concerne
tous pour en répondre à votre question
et aussi à son codicile par Jean-Lou
bourlange euh c'est regard c'est la
question du Maroc le Maroc contrairement
aux Émirats Arabes Unis a une opinion
publique Émirats arabes
unis la rente pétrolière a supprimé
cette chose embêtante de l'opinion
publique bah voilà population tout Simp
il y a une population mais oui nous
étions rencontrés avec Jean-Louis
broulange il y a maintenant une
vingtaine d'années pour le premier
colloque EUROGOLF à Abu Dhabi je
effectivement je n'avais pas fait
rencontrer l'opinion publique heureux
pays qui n'a pas d'opinion publique mais
d'autres en nont et le Maroc qui a
justement pactisé dans un un deal tout à
fait clair reconnaissance de la
marocanité du Sahara occidental en
échange de signature des accords
d'Abraham qui ont fourni au Maroc la
possibilité de disposer d'un armement
très
sophistiqué lui permettant de tenir à
distance les vieux chars soviétiques
algériens T54 au Sahara
euh or effectivement là alors le le le
roi du Maroc étant président du comité
al QUODS par exemple du comité Jérusalem
et c'est du reste l'une des raisons
parmi d'autres pour lesquelles nous
avons été la cible de
d'un certain nombre de d'Avan et de
critiques puisque désigner la France
ex-coloniale comme le la mère de tous
les vices et le père de tous les défauts
permettait aussi de faire tranquillement
le business avec Israël euh sans euh en
désignant un autre ennemi que
l'admissioniste entre guillemets
d'accord ça a d'ailleurs beaucoup changé
ces derniers temps on voit maintenant un
réchauffement euh franco-marocain qui
est depuis le 7 octobre des contrats
d'armement qui ne devaientêre passer
avec les Israéliens qui reviennent vers
la France les choses vont assez vite et
le effectivement euh vous
euh vous avez raison le
euh l'enjeu c'est que le processus
d'Abraham d'une certaine manière en ce
qu'il crée une dynamique économique
visant à la prospérité avec le typ
typiquement les les giviv les Jon
Ventures entre le capital du golf pour
l'essentiel et le et la et le Noa ouis
mais israélien bon le Maroc est un peu
différent le Maroc c'est à la fois il y
avait l'enjeu territorial c'està-dire la
question du Sahara et il y a aussi le
fait que le Maroc a une part de son
identité historique très importante qui
est juive et qui est reconnue comme tel
euh la fois bien sûr en diaspora vous
avez le le vote marocain est très
significative en Israël enfin le vote
juif marocain la ville de Nétivot que
vous voyez sur la carte en ce moment qui
est juste à la frontière de Gaza est une
ville peuplée de juifs marocains depuis
le début de Juifs de milieu très
modestes qui ont été envoyés là aussi
pour être le bouclier humain contre
contre Gaza je j'avais visité ntivot
j'avais vu une un bâtiment immense de
style marocain en milieu curieux qui est
qu' a une mosquée à nétivote pas du tout
c'est une synagogue de style marocain
sur laquelle était écrit en hébreu je ne
sais pas lire et en
français le les habitants de Nétivot
remerci Sa Majesté Hassan 2 roi du Maroc
commandeur des croyants pour avoir
favorisé la construction de cette
synagogue ici donc le message de lioté
vous savez oui c'est ça oui et
ou loté est mort avant la création
d'Israël donc c'estage Postume de lot et
donc
le C donc don il y a une dimension plus
plus complexe et plus humaine si vous
voulez pour le Maroc qui n'est pas le
cas pour les émirat et autres mais mais
mais mais le ressort fondamental le
pacte d'Abraham c'est les Émirats le
reste est secondaire Bahrein est là
parce que pour pour dire que l'Arabie
n'est pas contre parce que Bahrein est
complètement cette élite de l'Arabie
Saoudite
mais c'est enregistré tout ce qu'on
raconte c'est diffusé ou pas oui c'est
pas diffusé bon je si Sion
bonenregistrez vous ferez le montage
nécessaire pour éviter les rupur de
relation diplomatiqu et et donc le sinon
c'est sous votre responsabilité Mo j'ai
plus l'âge de voyager maintenant je
m'enfiche très bien bon et
donc donc alors les conséquences c'est
que à mon
sens
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt mis sur comment
on dirait en anglais sur le backburnner
c'est-à-dire ils ne n'ont pas renoncé
ils sont évidment mis dirigeants sont
mis dans la seringue entre le marteau et
l'enclume et ils ont un discours très
humanitaire c'est pour essayer de se
défausser par rapport à leur population
mais par exemple vous avez des
manifestations
proalestine quotidiennement à
Rabat et les Diplomat israélien sont
discrètement repartis
euh mais je pense que c'est un c'est un
repli tactique le processus ayant
vocation probablement il y a pas d'autre
solution à
être prolongé mais à condition d'y
intégrer la dimension palestinienne
justement c'est ça qui était le problème
parce que le président bourlange a dit
tout à l'heure en des mots que je ne
saurait égalé alors euh l'Europe la
visite de président Macron fait
effectivement contrairement à à au
président Biden il a pu lui aller voir
d'autres arabes les Iraniens ou leurs
supplétifs n'ont tiré aucun missile qui
la faisait dérailler il y a même un
signe plus important c'est qu'ils ont
libéré fariba
adelch notre collègue franco-iranienne
de sciencepo qui avait passé 4 ans et
demi dans les jaules Iraniennes sous un
prétexte Futi et qui a été libéré sans
justification autre que le message
envoyé au président de la République qui
pouvait aller qui pouvait aller lui dans
Voyage si vous voulez qu'on allait pas
qu'il n'y aurait pas d'hôpital qui
allait
exploser ce qui effectivement est un
signe aussi que tu j'ai interprété comme
tel que la la la médiation de l'Europe
et de la France c'est la bienvenue enfin
aussi pour dire que on veut d'autres
interlocuteurs que les Américains il
faut pas non plus faire d'illusion donc
donc voilà alors qui est une une
perspective européenne je crois que
c'est surtout la Méditerranée qui doit
jouer si vous voulez la Grèce l'Italie
la France principalement bon les autres
aussi peut-être n'oubliez quand même pas
que nous avons une autre guerre un peu
plus un peu plus au nord qui d'ailleurs
se se branche sur celle-ci au niveau de
la mer Noire qui est la guerre en
Ukraine et on en a pas du tout parlé
mais qui est effectivement la ce qui se
passe au Moyen-Orient fait partie d'un
système de crise euh qui qui bouleverse
complètement l'ordre ou le désordre
international qui se prolonge par la
fracture ukrainienne et qui euh
s'accomplit aussi dans la tension de
plus en plus forte avec la Chine dans le
Pacifique donc tout ça fait tout ça
sincrit dans un ensemble je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas si le Royaume-Uni est est
particulièrement allant euh dans ce dans
ce domaine en ce moment je va convainc
que le Royaume-Uni soit en capacité de
se projeter à l'extérieur vu la crise
intérieure qu'il reconnaît qu'il connaît
pardon manifesté par le fait qu'il
n'arrivera pas à avoir un TGV ce qui est
aujourd'hui quand même la marque de la
puissance pour les pays européens
VO merci merci le dernier orateur
inscrit au titre des groupes c'estàdire
c'est Monsieur David pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le député de la
Gironde c'est à vous merci monsieur le
Président professeur mes chers collègues
votre propos liminaire professeur
kepppel replace la France face à ses
responsabilité probablement face à ces
contradictions aussi et surtout face à
l'ampleur de la tâche au Moyen-Orient
dans le contexte actuel il me semble
essentiel de rappeler les positions
historiques et constantes des
socialistes la solution à deux états le
droit d'Israël à exister à se défendre
le respect absolu du droit international
rien en cela ne justifiera jamais ni
l'antisémitisme oou qu'il soit ni
l'attaque barbare don le Hamas s'est
rendu coupable le 7 octobre dernier
au-delà des complexités géopolitiques
face au terrorisme ce sont les principes
qui doivent primer avant tout c'est en
vertu de ces mêmes principes que nous
avons dès le début des hostilités appelé
à prendre une initiative diplomatique
pour un cesser le feu et à la raison
contre la tentation d'une vengeance à
aveugle vous avez analysé avec finesse
professeur kepppel les mécanismes des
rapports de force au Moyen-Orient et
leur recomposition depuis le mois
d'octobre il me semble d'autant plus
inquiétant de voir se dessiner notamment
par
l'implication opportuniste voire cynique
de la Russie dans le conflit une
nouvelle bipolarisation du monde autour
des tensions dans la région pensez-vous
que ce terme s'applique à la situation
actuelle née depuis le déclenche de la
guerre en
Ukraine ma seconde question porte plus
spécifiquement sur le rôle de la France
on a vu ces dernières années l'exécutif
faire preuve d'un volontarisme qui
confinait parfois au péchés d'orgueil je
pense notamment aux initiatives prise à
l'égard de Vladimir au début du conflit
en Ukraine vous appeliez fin septembre
la France a changé de logiciel avec le
monde arabe selon vous existe-t-il une
voix française spécifique sur le
Moyen-Orient dans la situation actuelle
par exemple face aux prises de position
américaines et comment voyez-vous vos
propos tenus le 29 septembre dernier à
la lumière des événements qui ont suivi
merci oui monsieur monsieur le
professeur Monsieur David vous pose une
question simple comment allons-nous nous
Français manifester notre qualité
essentiel qui est
l'humilité étant moi-même humble je vais
donc je m'exprimer en connaissance de
cause euh la le rôle merci beaucoup de
votre question euh la Russie s'est force
de de jouer un rôle anti-américain bien
évidemment dans le conflit
israëlpalestinien actuel puisque c'est
l'occasion de manif de gagner des points
parce que ce conflit a l'avantage aussi
de de réduire la la tension occidentale
vers euh et le le soutien à l'Ukraine la
capacité de de concentration sur
l'Ukraine se soutien je ne suis pas sûr
que les Russes soient euh pour l'instant
très gagnant dans dans cette affaire euh
vous avez vu que un avion qui se rendait
de té Aviv à Moscou a dû faire une
esclave technique dans la capitale du
Dagestan
ou euh une foule que je dont je ne pense
pas qu'elle est été manipulée par le KGB
c'est précipité à l'aéroport pour dire
où sont les juifs et les Israéliens
Allah Akbar on va leur faire la peau et
les bagarres qui ont suivi entre cette
foule très motivée et des policiers qui
avaient l'air avoir un peu de mal à
taper le taper dessus nindiique pas une
parfaite un parfait contrôle de la
situation musulmane dans le Caucase euh
la le Dagestan est à côté le linguti et
de la tchenie que la France connaît par
ses deux ress sortissant qui ont tué des
professeurs euh
le la situation est particulièrement
tendu pour pour Poutine et d'une
certaine manière lui aussi comme nous et
contrairement aux Américains à les
questions musulmanes comme un enjeu de
politique intérieure autant que de
politique extérieure voyez
donc Lavrov a bien fait quelques
déclarations récemment mais je suis pas
je suis pas convaincu pu que les Russes
soient dans une position extrêmement
forte pour tirer bénéfice de la
situation ils vont bien mettre un peu
d'eau d'huile sur le feu c'est normal
mais je ne pense pas que ça aille très
très loin
alors
euh qu'est-ce que vous m'avez demandé
oui la position de la France
euh en je crois que le enfin le la
tentative
d'amolir Vladimir
Poutine a donné ce qu'elle a donné euh
comme nous le savons
euh à mon sens comme je le ne ferais que
répéter ce que j'ai dit jusqu'àors euh
nous avons tout à fait intérêt à nous
positionner dans la sortie de crise dans
une perspective qui renouvelle la
dynamique régionale en
euh en considérant que le le processus
de de prospérité économique et clé mais
que les les Palestiniens pardon doivent
voir leurs droits respectés et en
recueillir également les fruits euh le
détail de tout cela on s'en occupera
plus tard si vous voulez c'est TR pas
moi mais il me semble que nous n'avons
pas d'autrre positionnement aujourd'hui
et que nos
interlocuteurs qui ont également intérêt
à la même chose ce sont l'Arabie
Saoudite et les Émirats principalement
avec le le Kow Qatar étant plus complexe
mais ce sont le c'est le le quadrilatère
qui possède les les clés du coffre si
vous voulez et qui eux-mêmes sont
contraints aujourd'hui d'agir parce que
euh il voit bien que ça les touche
directement et puis parce que c'est un
enjeu pour eux face à l'IR dernier point
peut-être pour une questionale tout le
monde
a AG glosé ça y est c'est la fin du
vieil Occident la médiation chinoise
regarde c'est formidable ils ont fait la
paix entre l'Iran et l'Arabie Saoudite
et bien la la truc la conclusion P c'est
n'est pas médiateur qui veut il suffit
pas d'avoir d'exporter de des du junk
dans le monde entier d'être un un empire
manufacturier pour que la médiation soit
soit respectée c'est c'est la c'est la
conclusion morale de cette oui qui
pourrait être partagé par Bernard
couchner euh madame pas
qu'allusion madame carois mais
maintenant les groupes ont parlé alors
c'est la situation est intenable j'ai h
h intervenants cette fois c'est comme
les groupes ont parlé les parlementaires
c'est une minute chacun et le l'invité
une minutes chacun donc là vous êtes
dans le vous êtes dans l'échange direct
et il faudrait qu'on termine vers 1h
vraiment etéonor c'est à vous une minute
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Professeur je vous remercie d'être parmi
nous aujourd'hui et nous avoir éclairer
sur la situation tragique au proche-
Orient je comptais vous interroger sur
le rôle de la France sur votre avis sur
la conférence humanitaire qui se tiendra
demain à Paris mais vous avez déjà
répondu donc passons j'ai quand même une
autre question très rapide en nous
livrant votre réflexion sur les
circonstances ayant mené à la terrible
attaque du 7 octobre vous avez rappelé
l'état de division et donc la fragilité
dans lequelle se trouvait Israël du fait
de la politique d'extrême droite mené
par le gouvernement de Monsieur
netaniiaahou si le pays apparaît uni
face aux attaques terroristes dont il a
été victime monsieur netaniaou semble
s'isoler sur le plan international en
tout cas c'est mon point de vue en ce
qu'il s'oppose aux demandes de trêve
humanitaire de ses alliés il semble
aussi faire relativement peu de cas euh
des dénonciations d'atteintes aux droits
humanitaires qui se font pour le coup de
plus en plus vives jusqu'ou peut-il
allit à votre avis plus généralement
vous faites un parallèle entre le 11
septembre américain et le 7 octobre
israélien nous nous souvenons tous des
années terribles qui ont suivi l'attaque
des tours jumelles et en particulier
l'enlisement de des États-Unis euh en
Irak et au euh et en Afghanistan
avons-nous suffisamment tiré les leçons
de ces conflits est-il possible de
répondre autrement que par une
démonstration de force lorsque l'on
apparaît pour reprendre votre expression
comme un géant au pied d'argile et je
vous avez le droit de r jusqu'à quelle
limite j'en sais rien mais pas au-delà
d'une minute merci beaucoup euh merci le
euh pardon euh
oui monsieur néaniaou le problème si je
do dire c'est que c'est monsieur
netaniaou qui mène l'offensive et que du
du point de vue même d'Israël ça serait
beaucoup mieux si ça n'était pas lui
puisque cela fait que ceux qui
voudraient soutenir Israël il regarde à
deux fois puisqu'il est considéré comme
étant l'un des grands responsables de la
situation actuelle
voyez en
73 les travaillistes ne se sont pas
relevés de l'absence de vigilance lors
de la guerre du ramadan ou du Kipour
comme vous voulez il est peu probable
qu'il s'en relève mais euh je remarque
néanmoins que c'est lui qui apparaît
comme menant la guerre aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus alors qu'on avait mis au
départ une sorte de trium vira avec
Monsieur Gans et Monsieur eisencott C
derniers sont peu visibles seul monsieur
lapide a pu dénoncer ses mensonges quand
il a dit jeade ne m'avait rien dit et
l'autre a dit mais si puisque
donc je euh je ne pense pas que qu'on
fasse comme on a fait après le 11
septembre puisque justement les
États-Unis ont tiré les leçons de cette
catastrophe comme vous l'avez rappelé et
le le le leg de l'Irak et de
l'Afghanistan est l'une des clés du
processus qui a conduit à mener les
accords d'Abraham dans l'esprit
trumpiste mais ce qui est assez frappant
c'est que c'est le leg de Trump qui a
été repris tel quel par byan voyez je
crois que j'ai pas le droit de continuer
mais je suis prêt à en parler avec vous
ultérieurement oui c'est voilà une bonne
idée
euh monsieur le professeur la parole
maintenant est à monsieur Adrien catn
pour fi voilà merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le professeur
et et directeur le gouvernement de
benjamine Netanyahou a échoué à assurer
la protection du peuple israélien en
encourageant une politique d'occupation
et de colonisation Israël mène une
guerre de siège qui pose beaucoup de
problèmes en droit international en
terme de crime de guerre et de crime
contre l'humanité nous nous sommes
essentiellement dans une politique de
vengeance la riposte israélienne n'est
pas ciblée ni proportionnée la légitime
défense n'est pas un droit à une
vengeance
indiscriminé Israël doit commencer à
faire ce qu'elle a peu fait dans son
histoire écouter la communauté
internationale la vengeance n'est pas la
réponse la réponse c'est la justice et
la justice passe par une solution
politique offerte aux
Palestiniens ces mots sont ceux de
Dominique de Villepin ancien Premier
ministre ancien ministre des Affaires
étrangères l'une des voix de la position
diplomatique historique de la France
cesser le feu libération des otages
lever du blocus et du siège de Gaza
couloir humanitaire solution politique
la France insoumise ne dit pas autre
chose comment expliquez-vous que le
débat politique et médiatique en France
sur ce sujet que vous connaissez bien
soit à ce point
dégradé monsieur le professeur merci
beaucoup j'avais effectivement noté que
la France insoumise se référait
maintenant à Dominique de Villepin
le confirmer euh le j'ai été détrôné oui
euh c'est vrai mais le
euh il me semble que
euh la la question
euh enfin il y a deux choses soit on est
ce qui est tout à fait votre rôle euh
dans euh une vision des choses où vous
favoriser la dénonciation de fait qui
vous semble inaccepable inqualifiable et
cetera et vous est tout à fait légitime
à le faire évidemment euh on vous dira
que vous F favorisez euh l'une des
exactions et que l'autre n'a pas la même
force dans votre propos on pourra le
dire si on souhaite c'est pas mon c'est
pas mon objet ici comme universitaire ce
que moi il me semble important euh de
partager avec vous c'est à la fois comme
l' incité au président une sorte de de
bilan global que bon chacun peut faire
ce qu'il veut mais en vous s'apportant
les les analyses de l' universitaire et
aussi les perspectives
euh je je pense qu'il n'est pas réaliste
de penser qu'on peut
aujourd'hui arrêter le l'offensive
israélienne jusque vous pouvez on peut
le dire on peut on peut souhaiter
qu'elle s'arrête on peut demander la
trêve mais je crois qu'il est irréaliste
de penser que les Israéliens sauf s'il y
avait une énorme catastrophe et même
comme cela pourrait s'arrêter avant
d'avoir réalisé le leur but de guerre
c'est-à-dire la destruction de
l'appareil militaire du Hamas pour les
raisons que j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
ou donc on peut bien
sûr les critiquer si on le souhaite
c'est légitime mais la la la position
qui est celle de de la de la France je
crois qui doit être celle de faire en
sorte que les droits du peuple
palestinien soit
euh défendu dans une étape qui suivra ça
me semble être la chose la plus
importante aujourd'hui vous voyez euh
maintenant ça ce sera obtenu bien sûr à
la fois du fait de ce qui se passera sur
le terrain et de ce que seront les
pressions des uns et des autres mais je
ne me fais guerre d'illusion sur le fait
que même des pressions américaines s'il
tentaiit qu'il voulait les mener pardà
le la façade pourrait aujourd'hui dévier
netaniaahou
ou le gouvernement et je crois que
là-dessous des Israéliens le suivent si
vous voulez globalement il y a il y a
même tous ceux qui sont très critiques
de netanahou qui considèrent qu'il est
responsable de presque tout sinon de
tout je n'ai je n'ai pas entendu en
Israël de voix significativ s'opposant
au but de guerre militaire voyez alors
aux exactions contre les civils oui bien
sûr mais c'est à peu près là je crois
qui est notre euh notre champ de
d'intéction des choses monsieur Hadad
monsieur le député du 16e
arrondissement de
Paris
pardon merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Professeur kpel j'avais deux
questions qui seront pas brèves donc
peut-être qu'on pourra en parler après
la première c'est peut-être sur
l'évolution du du Hamas vous y avez fait
référence le Hamas t était un groupe
teroriste qui est toujours opposé aux
accords de paix il y avait des attentats
déjà dans les années 90 contre les
accords de slow avec des explosions de
bus par exemple mais mais dans le mode
opératoire je pense que ça a quand même
surpris tous les observateurs à commencé
par les Israéliens c'est-à-dire
l'étendue de de la barbarie et en fait
une forme de dachisation de de la
méthode on peut penser aussi au aux
caméras GoPro et cetera est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a eu peut-être un un
changement là-dessus du du Hamas qu'on a
que les experts que les observateurs
n'ont pas vu ces ces dernières années et
ma deuxième question là aussi vous y
avez fait référence c'est sur le rôle
que pourrait jouer l'Arabie Saoudite
après dans la reprise d'une initiative
politique à Gaza et plus généralement
sur la la la cause
palestinienne merci pour ces questions
géopolitiques qui ne m'étonnent pas V de
vous avec l'expérience que vous avez euh
donc oui sur l'Arabie Saoudite j'ai déjà
répondu je pense que c'est il me semble
que c'est un c'est l'une des clés de l'
près c'est ceux qui ont l'argent euh il
faut va falloir qu'il s'aligne avec les
émirata un peu plus assez
compliqué mais il me semble que c'est
les initiatives qui seront prises avec
l'Europe ne peuvent se faire que dans ce
cette configuration là
et je crois que MBS mon sens est prêt à
ce genre de chos aujourd'hui là il a une
vision peut-être plus moins maniquéenne
qui qu'elle était autrefis alors
l'évolution de Hamas
effectivement comme je vous l'ai dit ce
sont des gens que que j'ai fréquenter
que le quelqu'un comme moi fréquente des
gens au MoyenOrient ne signifie pas que
je donne caution à leur politique sinon
je je n'ai pas fait grandchose non non
non mais c'est mais l'évolution est
double d'une part le l'alignement
complet sur l'Iran du fait
paradoxalement que les les les
l'islamisme politique sunnite a été
décapité elkaa en a plus DAEs plus
grand-chose sauf il un petit peu en
Syrie si vous voulez mais il y a plus la
capacité de projection internationale en
tout cas je pense qu'il y avait autrefis
et les Frères musulmans sont dans les
choux donc de ce fait il y a
l'instrumentalisation iranienne et en
effet les les images ce sont des images
où elkaida c'était les télévision par
satellite he pas paskaïa sans aljezira
daesh c'est les réseaux sociaux c'est
euh c'est Youtube qui a sa licence
d'exploitation le 14 février 2005 au en
Californie et daesh c'est la même
personne qui prend un otage lesgorge
face à la caméra et diffuse avec la
ressource de enfin du modèle économique
de l'Internet qui est la pornographie on
regarde l'horreur a ce sont pas des
victimes c'est pas du semblant c'est
vrai et ca euh et là ça a été d'autant
plus le cas que alors d'une part pour le
7 octobre d'une
part peut-être est-ce que ça avait été
mis en œuvre mais les GoPro ça fait
penser à Mohamed Mera Mera avait sa
GoPro ici c'est c'est le c'est le le
début de DA c'est c'est la GoPro c'est
c'est GoPro réseaux sociaux et et c'est
aussi le fait que un grand nombre de
gens au peut-être la moitié même de ceux
qui sont qui ont qui sont entrés sont
allés pour faire du pillage sans avir
sans en prenant l'opportunité voyez et
et donc le modèle c'est le modèle de
daesh parce que c'est celui qui s'est
imposé avec les exactions filmées
représenté qui aussi déshumanise
complètement l'ennemi qui en font un
mécréant dont le sang est licite et
d'autant plus un juif puisque bon ça a
été reprisment mais il y a ce fameux
hadith attribué au prophète qui sur la
fin des temps et où il y aura plus qu'un
musulman et un juif l'arbre derrière
lequel dissimuler le Juif va parler et
dire au musulmans musulmans un juif est
dissimulé viens et tule alors évidemment
dans le contexte actuel ce genre de je
crois qu'il y a eu deux imams qui ont
été expulsés en France récemment et les
gars pouvaient dire mais c'est dans le
recueil du Hadith et c'est vrai c'est
c'est un hadith canonique vous regard
comme le Wikipédia et autres fonctionne
uniquement sur les moteurs sur
l'algorithme c'est le nombre de
consultations vous regardez tout ce que
vous voulez aujourd'hui sur l'islam tout
ce qui sort s des sites salafistes et
c'est parfaitement si vous voulez c'est
la norme qui est en train de s'imposer
ce qui est il a une des RT là-dessus
pauvres RT qui sont aujourd'hui dans une
situation de misère absolue alors que la
question des signaux faibles est un
enjeu absolument majeur
oui
bien merci Monsieur Julien Laferrière
une
minute
voilà oui merci monsieur le professeur
vous vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
vous ne croyez pas cesser le feu
effectivement de l'opération déclenchée
à la suite de de l'attaque terroriste du
Hamas malgré les les milliers de de
victimes civiles peut-être plus de 10000
aujourd'hui première question est-ce
que on peut aujourd'hui parler de crime
de guerre à Gaza au regard du du droit
international
euh deuxème
question pour vous comment et quand
cette opération peut-elle se terminer
va-t-elle se se
terminé sur ce qui est de l'près vous
avez identifié les les acteurs les
acteurs internationaux notamment les les
P du golf euh dans cet apprêt j'allais
dire est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un aprêt
de de court terme c'est-à-dire un
respect des résolutions par Israël des
résolutions des Nations Unies notamment
en regarde la colonisation et sur le
long terme vous avvez dit vous savez pas
si la solution à deux états est possible
vous avez peut-être quand même une
petite idée parce que effectivement face
au morcellement de laass Jordanie
aujourd'hui de moins de moins de gens y
croi mais monsieur moisi l'autre jour
nous disait si il faut croire encore à
la solution à deux états donc j'imagine
vous avez quand même un avis je vous
remercie il est il est 13h 13h3 ça va
pas du tout j'ai encore quatre
intervenants je sais pas comment on va
faire alors ça va aller très vite parce
que les crimes de guerre c'est pas moi
qui peut qualifier ce qui se passe de
crime de guerre ou pas ça c'est une
question juridique internationale il y a
des gens dans c'est le métier moi je
n'ai pas ça ça dépasse ma
compétence quand ça va finir là je non
plus je n'ai aucune
idée
l'près je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
les résolutions de l'ONU qui a encore
aujourd'hui une efficacité l'ONU est
dysfonctionnel le vetto chinois le vetto
Russe font que ça neont pas fonctionner
ou vice-versa et c'est d'ailleurs l'un
des l'un des grands enjeux aujourd'hui
euh la solution à deux états euh
est-elle possible tout dépend de ce que
l'on met dans les deux états et
peut-être est-ce qu'on peut avoir une
forme de de création différente ça je ne
si Dominique moisi l'a dit c'est
certainement vrai mais je ne sais pas
comment sur de quel enfin on peut le
dire oui comme c'est comme un comme ce
qu'on souhaite la manière dont ça va
être mise en œuvre ça là-dessus je suis
dubidatif donc je suis désolé j'ai pas
été un très bon répondeur mais le
président met la pression aussi pour que
ce soit oui je mets la pression je peux
plus intervenir faire quelque chose de
normal donc je vais demander aux deux au
au au aux deux parlementaires du
rassemblement national d'une part et aux
deux parlementaires de RN de poser
successivement leurs questions euh et et
Monsieur le Professeur kepppel répondra
à à chaque à chaque groupe de deux si
vous n'y voyez pas d'inconvénient c'est
la seule solution que je vois monsieur
guign c'est pas pareil comment oui mais
non ça va pas si Monsieur mais comment
il est inscrit mais bon il est pas
allez-y allez-y monsieur Guignot c'est
par ici monsieur le Président oui je
juste pour quelques secondes monsieur le
professeur les pays occidentaux visés
par les invectifs du du Hamas je cite
entre guillemets appel à instauration un
régime théocratique musulman en
supprimant les juifs et les catholiques
fournissent tout de même une aide bien
sûr humanitaire aux Palestiniens les
pays qui soutiennent la Palestine
Tunisie Syrie Algérie Soudan Afghanistan
Qatar politiquement et militairement les
les islamiste du du Hamas fournissent-il
aussi une aide humanitaire voilà
oui euh on sait que le conflit
israëlo-palestinien est entré dans une
phase d'intensité exceptionnelle euh et
dans le cadre de l'engagement d'une
guerre ouverte d'Israël qui est une
puissance
nucléaire qui va provoquer peut-être un
risque d'équilibre pour la sécurité du
monde avec entoile de fond des conflits
avec l'Iran notamment euh donc je disais
l'Israël dispose de la bombe atomique
mais elle ne dispose pas de doctrine
officielle elle n pas membre enfin elle
est pas partie du du traité de non
prolifération par exemple donc elle
pratique l'ambiguité nucléaire est-ce
que vous pourriez nous indiquer si vous
avez des éléments qui qui qui qui sur
l'approche israélienne de l'emploi de la
force nucléaire et d'une arme
nucléaire stratégique ou tactique est-ce
qu'elle est révéellement envisageable
dans le cadre de ce conflit bon
merci merci don je n'ai je suis pas
compétent dans le domaine de
l'utilisation de l'arme nucléaire je le
regrette je crois qu'il vient d'y avoir
ce problème a été soulevé en Israël même
puisque un ministre de la coalition a
évoqué l'usage d'un d'une bombe
nucléaire tactique sur Gaza si je me
trompe pas et qu'il a été mis sur la
touche par Monsieur netaniaahou pour
avoir tenu des propos qui ne nétai pas
conformes à la aux règles d'engagement
en tout cas du gouvernement israélien
actuel mais je ne peux pas vous en dire
plus à ce stade euh la la question
nucléaire c'est surtout celle du seuil
de l'Iran aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si
l'Iran a la capacité
de bomber le torse de ce fait je n'en ai
pas ça n'est pas mon sentiment eu égard
au fait que l'Iran joue paradoxalement
une forme de désescalade tactique comme
le le l'a montré le non engagement de
Hezbollah dans les dans dans les
hostilités voyez à mon sentiment alors
excusez-moi le cœur de votre question
c'était militairement fournissentil une
aide
humanitaire alors écoutez je ne saurais
pas vous dire parce que la liste est
longue le le Qatar par exemple fournit
volontiers de l'aide humanitaire un peu
à tout le monde des raisons qui sont
aussi d'expédient un expédient politique
mais vous me prenez au dépourvu je n'ai
pas il faudrait avoir la la liste des
destinataires globalement j'ai bien
compris le sens obve de votre question
qui est c'est que il il n'en fournissent
pas beaucoup et que en l'occurrence nous
sommes les dindons de la farce
effectivement l'Union européenne
pourrait de temps en temps faire
attention à un certain nombre de crédits
qu'elle diffuse très largement je pense
chacun voit midi à sa porte au au
financement de l'Union européenne
destiné au aux universitaires proches
des Frères musulmans et qui sont
interdits en revanche à tous ceux qui ne
sont pas W
euh j'ai deux deux intervenants de
renaissance monsieur meer Habib est
arrivé à 13h5 13h5 dans une réunion qui
doit se terminer à 13h c'est quand même
ingérable je vous donne la parole une
minute mais c'est c'est pas possible ça
me met très en difficulté parce que je
dois recevoir à 13h donc j'ai djà un
quart d'heure de retard mon homologue du
Sénat et je voudrais pas discourtoi avec
lui parce que vous vous méprisez tous ou
pas tous vous en tout cas en
l'occurrence les les les horaires mais
comme vous êtes meilleur àible que je
vous connais bien que je vous aime
beaucoup je vous donne quand même la
parole mais brièvement merci Monsieur
Président si jamais je suis en retard et
je m'en excuse c'est que j'étais avec la
famille de la petite Mia qui a souhaité
de voir le l'ancien président de la
République à sa fille actuellement et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne suis
pas là et je m'en excuse auprès de
vous-même et jqu le PEL je crois pas
qu'il on doit avoir la moindre
agressivité là-dessus non mais je devais
être là mais il ils viennent d'ailleurs
à 2h à l'Assemblée nationale oui deux
questions brèves monsieur le professeur
sœ euh les gens parlent de crime de
guerre crime de l'humanité nous on sait
ce qui s'est passé à drest on sait ce
qui s'est passé à Berlin on sait ce qui
s'est passé en Normandie on sait ce qui
passa au de Boulogne Israël après les
est-ce que vous pensez vous-même après
euh qu'un groupe terroriste au niveau de
la loi de la guerre est-ce que vous
pensez que il peut avoir le moindre
crime de guerre de votre réaction par
rapport hier j'ai posté une réaction
d'une ancienne fonctionnaire Duqu d'orsé
j'ai vu que mon tweet avait fait près de
12 millions de vues euh je pensais
absolument pas de voir d'arracher des
des une une femme qui écait dans Le
Monde diplomatique arrachant les les
photos d'otage français alors qu'on a 8
français je voulais avoir votre votre
impression là-dessus sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans le pays j'ai qu'une
minute donc je pourrais pas aller très
loin mais vous avez compris les deux ch
j'ai rendu hommage à aux français
morts au 40 français morts et et et et
aux otages en début de cette réunion
allez-y monsieur Capel mais non mais
vous excusez pas vous nêtes pas obligé
d'être présent et vous avez les
meilleures raisons du monde de ne
pasêtre simplement vous pouvez pas
intervenir alors que la Réunion est
terminée voilà alors on tout à l'heure
on a ironisé sur le fait que l'Assemblée
nationale était beaucoup plus calme que
la ceset donc à votre arrivée prouve le
contraire ne voyez pas aucune allusion
perfide he dans donc en tout cas les
passion alors sur les crimes de guerre
j'ai répondu à votre collègue juste
avantre arrivver c'est que je n'ai pas
qualité moi-même pour me prononcer
là-dessus je pense ce
serait je peux prendre prendre une
position idéologique si vous voulez mais
je pense pas que c'est pour ça que je
sur le oui j'ai vu ce que vous avez
posté le tweet il s'agit d'une de mes
anciennes étudiantes alors ceci ne vaut
pas va vaut ne vaut pas tampon halal si
j'ose dire ou cacher comme vous préférez
mais oui j'ai
trouvé la vidéo qu'on voit est
effrayante et je crois qu'il y a eu une
une
réaction oui j'ai vu il y a eu une
réaction mais mais elle n'est pas
diplomate he elle a elle a elle a fait
de la la consultation je crois que c'est
plus elle n'est pas elle n'est pas agent
de l'État en tout cas alors j'ai
l'impression que dans le tweet original
éta incriminé comme agent de l'État
non non enfin oui c'était ambigu faisait
des conférences enfin pas a voilà ça
n'est pas un agent de l'État
comment oui oui c'est voilà donc vous
voyez que même même les les professeurs
qui forcent sont parfois des étudiants
qui font des choses qui après t les les
étudiants sont libres de faire ce qu'ils
veulent y compris de critiquer leurs
professeurs voir de tenter de tuer le
père mais le père est toujours
là dernière question beaucoup de respect
pour les professeurs oui j'ai été giré
par les professeurs quand j'étais au
lycée donc je que c'est un partout
monsieur Monsieur parquan et Madame
delpèche est-ce que vous tenez
vraiment allez-y bah oui pas plus en
tout cas oui monsieur le
Président merci merci pour vos lumières
ah pardon
merci pour vos lumières cher professeur
Gilles Keppel je sais que vous
travaillez beaucoup sur l'islamisme en
France depuis le début du conflit Israël
au palestinien nous voyons qu'il existe
une résonance de ce conflit dans la
société française et qui tend à
s'accroître cette résonance
malheureusement provoque de nombreuses
fractures dans notre société parce que
je ne supporte pas que notre pays soit
divisé parce que je ne supporte pas que
la fraternité SEM être la grande oublié
de notre devise républicaine en cette
période troublée j'ai décidé cette
dernières semaines d'aller à la
rencontre de de tous les responsables
religieux de ma circonscription
catholiquees Arméniens protestants
orthodoxes musulmans juifs et boudhistes
ces rencontres je rassembler à créer à
créer du lien et à réunir sans aucune
distinction de culture ou de religion
nous avons à Marseille où je suis député
une instance qui s'appelle
marseilleesérance qui rassemble toutes
les religion et dont le fondement et le
respect de chacun le dialogue et
l'amitié cette initiative apparaît comme
une hulur d'espoir monsieur le
professeur notre pays a besoin d'unité
d'apaisement pour ne pas créer de
nouvelles fractures de nouvelles
blessures nous avons nous devons agir
mais aussi et surtout créer les
conditions du dialogue que pensez-vous
de cette idée de dialogue interreligieux
pouvons-nousz la poser en en commençant
pouvez-vous qu'une déclinaison nationale
de ce type d'instance puisse être une
solution aux fractures de notre société
merci Monsieur Merci alors je ne suis
pas le dialogue interreligieux à
certainement sé ver on avait madame
delpèche d'ord qui devait pardon pardon
mais j'ai terminé ma réponse il a ses
vertus mais à mon avis elles ne sont pas
suffisantes dans la République laïque
parfait voilà voilà une réponse madame
delpèche merci monsieur le Président je
fais très court j'associe ce pointant
mon collègue Adrien Gomi à cette
question vous avez évoqué le hzbollah
mouvement terroriste libanais soutenu
activement par l'Iran qui a pris la
parole pour la première fois depuis le
début de la guerre il a précisé qu'en
qu'une guerre totale était réaliste
soulignant que toutes les options
étaient sur la table concernant le front
libanais contre Israël nous savons que
le Hezbollah est très puissant il compte
des députés au Parlement libanais il est
il a également une force militaire
importante avec 30 à 30000 à 100000
hommes et de gros moyens financiers
provenant du régime iranien les
États-Unis se sont dit prêts à frapper
le hzbollah et l'Iran comme en témoign
l'envoi de porte-avion et d'un
sous-marin lanceur de missile américains
monsieur le professeur craignez-vous que
le Hezbollah soutenu par l'Iran
rentrerait réellement dans ce conflit
entraînant une guerre totale je vous
remercie merci Madame j'ai mentionné
tout à l'heure que à mon sens il ne le
faisait pas parce que à l'heure actuelle
c'était un risque pour sa main mise sur
le Liban par que vous pouvez ajouter à
votre catalogue que le Hezbollah
contrôle le Liban aujourd'hui ce qui est
la raison pour l'appauvrissement du pays
que les Saoudiens ne veulent plus mettre
un S au Liban tant que c'est le hzbola
qui contrôle les choses concrètement
donc voilà où on en est où
aujourd'hui euh alors je vous juste dire
un mot qui a peut-être fâcher certains
d'entre vous
euh on peut dire bien sûr que Hamas et
Israël sont des mouvements terroristes
si on le souhaite moi je n'ai pas
utilisé l'expression pourquoi parce que
au départ et c'est une différence
peut-être avec daesh même si je ne sais
plus qui a posé la question de la
dachisation de c'est vous c'est ça que
je crois c'est très juste si vous voulez
mais euh au départ contrairement aux
groupes terroristes ultra minoritaires
que sont daesh ou qui était al-qïda ce
sont des mouvements qui ont une
implantation populaire qui n'est pas
négligeable alors c'est vous me direz
les nazis aussi av des implantation
populaire certainement mais euh les les
réduire uniquement à cette qualification
me semble n'être pas utile pour leur
analyse même si on veut les combattre
puisque ils ont une véritable
implantation populaire ce qui n'était
pas le cas d' ni le cas de d'alqaeda
voyez donc le euh maintenant c'est après
chacun porte les jugements qu'il veut
mais le le le le point de vue de de
l'universitaire c'est que enfin de celui
que je suis en tout cas j'essaie d'être
c'est c'est qu'il faut
euh tenter de
percevoir ces ces mouvements dans toutes
leurs dimensions et la analyse c est
fondamentale ce pourquoi je terminerai
encore si le président M autorise par un
vibrant plédoyer auprès de l'Assemblée
nationale pour qu'elle se penche sur
l'effondrement des études arabes dans
l'université française ou la recherche
des causes et des faits est remplacé par
l'idéologie qui à mon avis est une
catastrophe et après tout c'est vous qui
décidez des crédits et vous avez le
droit de vous exprimer je vois que le
professeur Keppel ne désespère pas crois
à l'Assemblée nationale
déjàutre le dernierutêtre le dernier
c'est le dernier en France à considérer
que le Parlement
existe compte à part nous évidemment qui
bon écoutez je je suis entièrement je
crois que tout le monde sera d'accord et
c'est d'ailleurs une des leçons qui
s'est dégagé de notre du rapport
précédent sur l'Afrique à savoir que
l'investissement cognitif comme on dit
maintenant l'investissement intellectuel
comme dirait plutôt comme on disait
plutôt du temps de Monsieur Rena non la
réforme intellectuelle est absolument
essentielle si on veut retrouver un un
discours une présence qui soit
véritablement adapté à à au monde et sur
je suis j'ai suivi comme vous la les
modifications les transformations et la
dégradation de l'enseignement notamment
à Science Po je le regrette profondément
et je je crois que nous avons un énorme
effort sur le plan intell à entreprendre
si nous voulons en tant que puissance
moyenne puisque nous ne sommes plus la
très grande puissance que nous étions
àagur mais si nous voulons avoir en tant
que puissance moyenne une juste et
pertinente influence l'investissement
intellectuel est essentiel je crois
monsieur le professeur que s'ajoutant à
toutes les observations que vous avez
faites et qui est d'un très grand
intérêt celle-ci est cardinal et sera
reçu je crois absolument par l'ensemble
des groupes merci en tout cas
merci je n'ai pas je ne suis pas déçu
une fois de plus de vous avoir invité et
vous êtes chez vous hélas la situation
continuera de ne pas aller bien et donc
vous serez toujours nécessaire
malheureusement quand on me voit la
télévision c'est que ça va pas je voilà
merci merci de votre écoute et merci là
la séance après les membres la séance
est levéci merci beaucoup